let's go on va voir si neige ou pas
il neige à Cannes bah à Cannes quand il
neige on n'a pas de problème
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai pas les chiquer
ça je sais pas je vais essayer d'appeler
Bakis j'ai réussi à l'avoir
incroyable ce truc de neige
va de façon pour moi j'ai mon premier
setup
qui est bien
alors j'étais comment j'étais comme ça
j'étais comme ça
on va essayer de récupérer Maxime
non mais c'est une admissible en fait
qui perd pas du temps à la pendule à
cause de sa [ __ ] de neige
enfin moi je m'en fous qui nage enfin je
comprends pas en fait
ça me rend fou déjà
je comprends pourquoi quand tu es
déconnecté tu perds et que c'était pas
connecté à cause de neige pourquoi tu
joues en fait je comprends pas ça me
dépasse
ça va bah qui tu m'entends salut Kevin
ouais c'est la pire excuse
partie on va perdre la partie et là le
mec il neige qu'est-ce que j'en a [ __ ]
qui nage en fait
désolé un bac il a je suis un peu énervé
mais bon
soit il y a des règles elles sont
suivies soit il y a pas de règle et de
demain Maxime il sort son CEB et je n'y
arrive à jouer le Boo pas l'air enfin je
sais plus en fait c'est Hikaru il peut
regarder sur son écran pendant les
parties il se passe rien enfin
j'ai pas au bout d'un moment
il y a des gens en fait
bon écoute tu as ta cam
alors
attends on appelle alors attends allumer
la caméra
ça c'est cool
non non mais bon il faut que les règles
soient claires c'est soit on a le droit
de faire ce qu'on veut et on fait ce
qu'on veut et nous on va on va attaquer
de pas on va gagner les matchs 20-0
aussi attention Carlson tu vas voir nous
on va jouer avec deux écrans aussi
on va faire neiger aussi chez lui
c'est la deuxième fois pour moi
[Musique]
non plus je sais pas mais c'est pas
grave
faut que je m'installe
j'ai quand même eu le temps de me raser
avant le match important
et ça joue là non ça joue pas je sais
pas si ça a joué écoute moi j'ai rien
qui s'ouvre j'ai des caméras qui
changent toutes les trois secondes
déjà qui règle leur caméra que ils se
s'installe mais je vois pas soit acide
déjà donc je pense pas que ça joue
pour moi il y a déjà un 0 pour Maxime
hein
bientôt deux 19h05 c'est 3000 5 minutes
par partie donc c'est un forfait pour le
moment il y a pour moi il y a un zéro
déjà enfin je vais faire peut-être mes
propres vous pouvez peut-être arriver
tout pile Wesley on l'a vu quand même un
petit peu il était peut-être tout pile
alors attends ça me plaît pas moi ma
dispo là moi tout pile ou pas tout pile
pour moi il y a 5-0 tu vois c'est je
sais pas comment dire en fait c'est oui
tout pile peut-être mais il y a 5-0
je vais je vais récupérer ta carte on va
tout récupérer petit à petit
je pense qu'on fasse un comptage
[Musique]
on va tous s'installer en technique là
je suis pas bien pourquoi
de toute façon là il y a le temps je
vais te dire c'est pas près de commencer
c'est pas près de commencer il y a les
caméras qui changent d'endroit les
machins il y a ceux qui vient qui
reparle Maxime qui vient qui part
et si c'est peut-être mieux non que je
me mets directement si je suis sur
cheesecom c'est pas mal non comme ça
j'ai le chat un petit peu aussi
j'aime pas trop le visuel du discord
je suis pas hyper fan du visuel donc
comme tu veux
alors
j'ai mes amis
il est même pas je suis même pas mis
avec Maxime c'est Maxime qui est pas mis
avec toi quand même ça j'en ai parlé
avec Maxime il m'a dit oui t'inquiète
t'es pas mis avec Baki moi non plus
tu vois il sait
quand même par contre je suis ami avec
mdlet
avec vous monsieur
tu es quand même pas bien là tout d'un
coup
je l'ai
pas encore
le kakistan est quand même assez
puissant bah qui
risque de la prendre un jour à tes
dépens
alors est-ce que tu penses qu'il est
favori ce soir Maxime ou tu penses que
c'est 55 ans
[Musique]
de la même façon
donc tu mettrais quand même un peu
devant
surtout que dans les tout ça il était
pas mal
il a l'air devant je pense que Wesley
moins bon
pour moi c'est très difficile à juger
aussi je pensais vraiment 50/50 du coup
je pense les 5
si Wesley prend pas d'avance au début je
pense que Maxime sera favori mais
ça c'est toujours
on verra on verra après Maxime il a
peut-être le match en fond aussi non non
il m'a dit qu'il avait pas il m'a dit
qu'il l'avait pas
mais t'inquiète
ah non je pense qu'il
d'habitude quand il l'a il le dit Maxime
un petit peu quand même au moins les
résultats
il va quasiment pas rater le match en
fait c'est le match
ah ouais là si tu voulais
au bout de deux parties c'était déjà
ça a quand même duré 4 heures parce
qu'on voulait vraiment être sûr
c'est important
c'est important ça commence pas quoi il
faut lui laisser le temps de retirer sa
veste préparer un thé il faut quoi pour
Wesley là je sais pas écoute j'en sais
rien j'ai pas je sais pas ce qui me fait
là où Wesley
mais je trouve ça inadmissible
parce que gère le moment où Maxime il va
avoir une déco en fait il a une déco
quand tu restes 10 secondes il y a
personne qui va lui rendre le Punto en
fait moi c'est ça qui m'agace c'est que
que on a iponceau si tu veux en disant
machin on attend et tout moi il y a pas
de problème il y a pas de problème
là-dessus j'ai zéro problème mais le
jour où Maxime il va lui rester 8
secondes et il est déco et qui se
raconterai carreau il y a personne qui
va rendre le point je me rappelle en pro
dece Lee car de finale ou 8e de finale
on perd contre l'équipe d'icaru on perd
sur une déco de Maxime serveur il y a
personne qui nous rend le point donc au
bout d'un moment c'est soit on rend
jamais le point à personne soit il y a
des gens au bout d'un moment on passe on
passe le froc quoi
c'est un peu ce qu'on a fait face à
Hikaru dans ce match c'est vrai mais
j'accepte j'accepte je dis rien je dis
ok c'est arrivé comme ça ça arrive quand
même de quoi il y a pas enfin on a perdu
c'est c'est on est responsable des
connexions il y a rien mais mon Dieu
pourquoi quand c'est les autres il y a
il y a jamais rien
bah désolé bah qui c'est un peu le coup
de gueule mais parce que on a un peu
l'impression de se faire en flash à
chaque fois
mais bon il est tellement derrière
Wesley que c'est pas grave ouais mais
c'est pas grave aujourd'hui mais un jour
ce sera grave les jours où ce sera grave
on va de nouveau se faire
pourquoi ça joue pas ça
voulu mettre une pub encore c'est
peut-être ça en fait toutes les règles
je pense
je le mettrai après c'est moi j'ai mis
une petite compte à rebours
je chapperai un peu plus tard allez
c'est bon on allait partir pour le
moment c'est 0 0
peut-être une petite nulle pour
commencer Baki
non
pas de nul pour commencer excuse-moi
ce que tu vois la partie c'est ça
l'important moi je l'ai en tout cas nous
on l'a et c'est une nageoire
donc Maxime il avait joué plutôt avec E5
comme sa partie contre
c'est très dur de jouer pour le gain
quand même pour les Noirs il faut bien
connaître pour faire nul parce que j'ai
4 c'est un peu plus risqué ça donne ça
donne du jeu ça donne des possibilités
de
jouer pour gagner aussi le même si c'est
probablement
dans la théorie mais pour le Blitz tout
adapter
et petite petite chose importante
d'ailleurs à souligner
il y aura
le les demi-finales et finales de se
joueront pas exclusivement demain et
après demain d'après ce que j'ai compris
là il y aura une demi-finale demain à
15h l'autre demi-finale vendredi et la
finale mardi tout a est re-été décalé
une nouvelle fois mais ce sont pas des
informations définitives que je vous
donne parce que ça pourrait évidemment
rechanger
pour pour la fin et on me dit que tu as
un petit un petit une petite difficulté
sur le son bah qui
sur le son des fois ça part un petit peu
si tu peux jeter un œil
dans ton dans tes paramètres discord
des fois il part un petit peu je sais
pas si tu as si jamais il y a un loup de
Vicks sinon tu fais
faut pas le permettre de faut rien lui
permettre en fait si demande s'il peut
se
couper ou quoi aléatoirement ne laisse
pas faire
ok ne te laisse pas victimiser par ce
micro backi
ouais c'est ce que je pensais pourquoi
pas
ce qui a été joué par Wesley dame B6
maintenant
jouet
je pense moi j'aime bien la position
pour les Noirs là tu as du jaune quand
même
ça sera probablement mieux pour les
blancs mais là pour le blé c'est parfait
tour C8 mais pour trouver une défense
c'est quoi là c'est
facile
en réalité il y a le cavalier en plus
j'ai quatre qui va pouvoir revenir vers
ces quatre au cas où
c'est l'idée
EC4 et tape la dame et tape B2
des très très bien et tu peux même un
jour si jamais tu veux faire rentrer la
tour à chute faire du roi des 7
peut-être bon bien plus tard mais ça
peut même ne pas être si grave d'avoir
le rond en 17 en fait c'est une position
idéale même le
blanc ils ont pas vraiment on dirait
mieux que c'est quasiment mieux pour les
Noirs ici
déjà à côté
après si jamais saut il en a marre du
jeu contre Maxime en moment donné il
pourra faire un bonhomme de neige dehors
c'est peut-être ce qu'il faisait c'est
pour ça qu'il qu'il voulait décaler le
match en fait c'est ça c'est
j'ai une idée fantastique c'est bon
j'arrive j'ai réussi à mettre mon setup
et être
très très bien là
j'ai tout j'ai tout j'ai l'échiquier
j'ai le chat j'ai tout j'ai
est-ce qu'on peut être bien est-ce qu'on
peut dire que le plan de Maxime est
assez sommaire
c'est pas possible
il y en a qui sont qui sont prêtes
évidemment
ça ça se prépare pour les matchs comme
ça
il fait cavalier C4 il voulait empêcher
le cavalier 5 et C4 qui a laissé quatre
je suis pas hyper fan qu'elle a joué
vite
[Musique]
il est vraiment il est vraiment très
très bien là c'est
très très dur à jouer pour pour Wesley
CO2
renforcer avec C3 peut-être
c'est peut-être le moment pour petit
rock
ouais on a envie de petits retenir
on y va
de 50 contre 27
joli coup pour jouer C3 et bien renforcé
de sacrifier la tour reprend des 4 qui
est prend des quatre fous prends à deux
Maxime
ça a l'air ça a pas l'air suffisant mais
c'est un gros coup de consolidation on
pensait qu'il allait la Sommer mais
il s'en sort pour le moment
et cavaliers
mais là j'ai un peu peur d'un coup comme
F5
tu vois par exemple F5 fou D7 full 7 au
FC 8 F6 dans ce genre là
il va peut-être voir sacrifier quelque
chose d'un maximum
il est peut-être dans la sauce là Maxime
en fait j'ai vu un peu tard mais dès
qu'il a fait petit rock je me suis dit
ah il y a pas F5 là
et
ça peut pas être difficile à jouer ça
elle est dure en réalité alors qu'elle
paraissait tellement bien mais j'ai
l'impression que soit vraiment jouer les
bons coups hein
on va prendre deux fois et après d'un
proche c'est très proche de Mathéo aussi
alors peut-être qu'il peut tenter fou
des selfs pour éviter ce cavalier prend
F6 voilà ça j'aime
ça c'est bien joué bakinant
ok il y a du
Maxime qui commence à se mettre en place
toi c'est 8 qui fait qui fait mal
si après ça paraît
ça paraît difficile ça va faire un zéro
pour un saut fermé à double tour dans
cette partie
c'est bizarre il y a toutes les pièces
noires qui tapent le roi dame B6 torse
j'ai 7 x 2 même cavalier G4 qui peut
vite arriver par au 5c4 on peut
retrouvera toutes les pièces noires
attaque mais ouais le b2c3 c'est très
très solide c'est trop solide c'est trop
solide
après bon il avait une bonne position
qui a raison de
bateau
les petits retards les machins
jamais il faut jamais rien donner
jamais un demi
pointer au noir
dans la deuxième
non parce que là faut prendre un point
H6
vous prend des quatre un belle variante
pour pour les meilleurs
style à voir je sais pas si tu as les
flash mais faut prendre faut prendre 4
tours des câbles prend des quatre il y a
de H7 échec où elle fait damashe8 il
encaisse la tour C8 après pas facile à
voir mais pas pour pour le chat mais
pour leur niveau c'est quand même assez
c'est dans leur corde assez fin assez
facilement une fois qu'ils sont entrés
dans la variante c'est facile mais bon
ça joue pas à grand chose quand même
c'est quand même pas de chance
en premier cavalier F5 peut-être
pièce aussi l'autre éclairée mais qui va
y être 5
pense à faire un zéro pour Wesley ça
fait un peu chier mais écoute c'est
comme ça
joue encore
où ça joue la même berlinoise que
simcafield
comme les scores sont dans l'autre sens
je vais devoir je dois remettre les
trucs dans l'ordre
et je suis avec toi dans une seconde
mais normalement avec les Blancs il va
dominer Maxime non contre Wesley tout
dépend parce que là regarde c'est la
finale de la berlinoise alors ça dépend
à quel point Wesley se souvient
mais attention au final de la berlinoise
je trouve que c'est quand même plus
facile à jouer en langue
parce que
avec les Blancs
quand même donc bon on va voir comment
il a révisé est-ce qu'il a pas de
nouveaux coups ici
après maxi pourra toujours changer
d'ouverture il peut tester sa lampe en
premier et puis à l'autre part
mais c'est vrai qu'il a toujours eu du
mal contre
c'est dur de lui mettre vraiment un gros
grosse pression au blanc
elle avait gagné
sauf qu'il y avait gaffé rapidement dans
l'ouverture
F5 il a fait reprendre si ça tempo
ça j'ai plus trop quand
on veut garder les faux et GF5 ça peut
sembler à la partie de Maxime contre
caryakin
il y a 4 ans
je crois
attention j'aime pas attention parce que
ce genre de ligne ça tourne vite
je suis pas hyper fan pour le moment
en fait
il évite les C5 mais par exemple tu vois
ici faut baisser tu vas attendre un peu
quoi faut B7 encore
qui peut se retrouver en danger mais il
va faire fois 6 pour gagner un tempo sur
la tour fait tourner il avait aussi fou
assis cette tour à D8 qui avait l'air
très très tranquille voilà c'est pas
mieux du tout pour maximum je pense que
même
[Musique]
ok garde le tour des selles c'est pour
ça que tu aurais 8 c'était tu vois si
c'était
déjà c'est déjà ça va
[Musique]
ça peut passer pour les problèmes
mais il y a du tout au 5 non aussi à 5
ou F4 ou C5
attention à mes tours 5 G4
ça peut être pas mal en plus ça prend
pour avoir du tout rachat peut-être pour
décaler
mais ouais c'est pour ça je fais les
deux trois derniers coups là de Wesley
sont un peu moyen
s'il arrive à fu F4
il le fait
tu auras des 8 ça a l'air OK pour les
Noirs mais c'est pas ça peut plus être
dangereux pour pour les blancs
Maxime qui rentre qui joue quand même
pas mal ainsi continue à jouer comme ça
ça va finir par s'effriter côté saut
donc ouais
il va l'armure l'armure de sauve à
va commencer à s'effriter petit à petit
c'est un peu comme au tennis il faut pas
il faut pas trop paniquer quand un
adversaire joue bien il joue bien et
puis si toi tu restes dans ton jeu et
que tu continues ça finit par passer
même si on a l'impression que ça bloque
un peu notre tour F3 qui se met pas dans
la diagonale du fou et ça contrôle deux
aussi
attention quand même ça peut il y aura
pas pierre jusqu'à va laisser trois
retours des trois c'est peut-être bien
joué
[Musique]
pour le coup je pense que
ça me paraît
ça joue à deux résultats là pour moi
plutôt dans le mauvais sens
fou et vraiment fort
et puis on s'en fout
ce qu'on a des pions doublés c'est 5 et
c'est 7 mais le 43
on peut pas réussir à doubler colonne G
[Musique]
quand même
même tour C8 cavalier aussi
je vais commencer à te menacer des tours
des 7 pour te pour te claquer une carte
attention
ça fait plaisir d'avoir ce coup quand
même ça a été raté par Wesley il a raté
un truc
alors
ça commence à être nettement mieux pour
les blancs
F4 tours un truc en tout cas
après la position elle était assez bien
pour les Noirs donc ça reste
ça reste pas si clair il va falloir bien
jouer pour la gagner
[Musique]
probablement mais là il a pas trop de
casse d'entrée quand même
il est bloque ado
et il va faire tourner
il a peut-être des H4
pour torcher 3
un tour des deux il y avait peut-être H4
[Musique]
non pas trop le choix
j'avais pas pas facile pour
dans ces cas je C3 est la tour elle est
ouais ok c'est fini c'est Punto pour
Maxime alors leur gagnant après cavalier
C7
c'était catastrophique quoi il n'était
pas facile à voir si c'était la seule
défense tu vois c'était la seule
ça faisait partie
mais depuis tout requête depuis tout
recettes il fait une partie
catastrophique Wesley
il va faire quoi X à 4 seul coup de
toute façon et la B3
[Musique]
j'aime bien tout aussi
parce qu'on gagne pas est-ce qu'on prend
pas toute la maison comme ça
tout réussi c'est chèque tour des 6 on
va prendre FC c'est le cavalier les
pièces noires sont mal coordonnées pour
attaquer le roi blanc en tout cas c'est
la première ligne tu réussisses en D6
Baki que tu as trouvé moi j'étais plutôt
sur B3 mais qui est pas du tout première
ligne
j'ai été déconnecté
mais attention Maxime là qui joue pas
quand même il faut
quand même garder du temps ah c'est bien
joué ça aussi avec cavalier de D5 pour
se garder ton point F6 c'est du tour
j'ai un peut-être pour venir prendre
Wesley à revers
ça a l'air d'être très bien joué
français toi FC il va partir en
8 peut-être avec le roi
des 8 suppose mais surtout des 6 il y
aura pas un roi C8 qui a eu 7 il est
encore roi C7 qui tourne C6 3 B7
qui va partir
et qu'on va plus revoir côté Wesley
allez c'est légalisation pour Maxime
ça suit un peu côté Wesley quand même et
ça fait du bien
ça change côté Maxime elle fait du bien
cette victoire tout de suite pour se
remettre dedans faut pas laisser
l'adversaire dans dans ce format
s'échapper
c'est ce que je veux souvent en title je
vais peut-être apprendre quelque chose
pour les noix pour pour les blancs
Soliman en title
MP3 voilà ça sera mon prochain coup ça
me prépare pour mardi bizarre non qu'il
soit parti sur une Rousseau
quand les matchs sont longs quand tu
gagnes tu retournes non un peu quand
même pas du tout
en fait ça avait l'air pas mal mais
Wesley là quand même bien bien joué
cette neige d'or moi je trouvais que
c'était bien aussi toi aussi mais sur
les coups au final
c'est une position qui que Wesley a bien
maîtrisé donc il change pour se loger
encore une fois dedans mais ouais tu as
peut-être raison il se lave peut-être
pour plus tard remarque tu me diras il
va pouvoir revenir dessus mais ça dépend
voilà il va tester une ou deux
ouvertures dès qu'il trouve quelque
chose ou ça va bien ce soir il va il va
répéter la berlinoise c'est possible
qu'il change aussi parce que l'ouverture
elle était pas
il a gagné vraiment sur des erreurs
après donc je sais pas on verra
en tout cas c'est son choix il a senti
et Wesley qui a peut-être appris le
français parce qu'il joue au casse noir
toutes les cases noires
et Maxime qui se bat aussi hein
il se fait la case G5 pour le cavalier
il a pas été curieux de tenter des
quatre et d'ouvrir une silienne
d'ailleurs
de son côté pour voir ce que
c'est quand même
de changer alors le pion pro FC c'est
très bizarre de la part de Wesley je
voyais plutôt le cavalier des trois
direct
parce que là en fait moi structure elle
est symétrique et Maxime juste la paire
de faux et le cahier de Détroit qui est
très très bien pris
la position de Maxime est assez
magnifique non je préfère je préfère
Maxime
ici à la sortie de l'ouverture et là
vraiment une position saine
pour le moment pour Maxime
la Beck up influence le monde et oui la
case noire de Mazet sont partout je veux
bien ce maso il joue tellement bien maso
F2
Wesley Maxime qui prend la priorité sur
toutes les diagonales importantes
sur toute la position en fait
il se place sur la colonne
jouer colonnes évidemment
les tours c'est pas grave d'échanger les
tours ici parce que les faiblesses vont
se faire
avec moins de pièces et on verra bien
les faiblesses quand même il attend toi
je pense qu'il va jouer toi quand même
il va colmater
va pas vouloir laisser rentrer une tour
en 7
d'avoir envie d'échanger ses tours
quand même
moi je trouve que c'est plutôt plutôt
bien plus de les échanger ok il le fait
après il peut en échanger une et faire
[ __ ]
elle est quand même importante je trouve
par rapport à la colonne
ce pion des 4 quand même il peut être
faible un jour il y a des cases pour
rentrer par derrière
encore plus de faiblesse dans la
position blanche
après c'est pas si mal en fait
et pas compris ce cours
je sais pas c'est pas c'est pas logique
pour moi
et jouer pour kb4 cavalier C6 aussi
peut-être tu fixes à 7 quand même
[Musique]
en tout cas visuellement
il y avait fout des deux aussi
qui devrait pas mal de pièces en
touchant le fouet
il s'est créé une case en B5 à le a5 de
Maxime était pas
je sais pas
ça a l'air d'être intéressant
[Musique]
il y a tout réussi ce qui arrive quand
même
[Musique]
c'est sûr que c'est mieux pour les Noirs
cavaliers C4 le bon fou contre le
mauvais fou
là ça va dépendre du thème pour deux tu
as raison c'est un bon coup
c'est juste prisé
[Musique]
où j'ai 5 comment il défend sur la
menace qui est
je pense pas qu'il puisse défendre
[Musique]
un pull je sais pas ce qu'il a foutu
il a vu que son contourner était
catastrophique
prise il faut H6 un bâtiment
pour essayer de gagner la casse pour le
cavalier quoi il s'est activé
après parce qu'il a fait un petit
sourire quand Maxime la jouer et ça fait
ça fait deux ans allez on peut faire un
premier un premier écart
c'est logique
il a pas le choix ici ils vont tester il
va en tester deux trois de petites idées
sur la
[Musique]
après c'est plutôt une bonne chose
dans le match il va jouer toutes ces
tournois parce qu'il va pousser des
petits avantages sans risque
pas de solution avec les blancs en fait
il est déjà quasi fermé pour le match
ok je joue avec le pion dessin c'est pas
mal emblée
[Musique]
est-ce que tu peux venir avec le micro
il continue à avoir un petit un petit
souci est-ce que tu peux regarder dans
le son si il y a s'il y a un truc qui
qui te ferme le micro quand tu parles
bas un truc d'attaque
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a ça je sais
plus comment ça s'appelle peut-être
Ludwig va nous dire dans le chat
juste pour qui un seuil ouais peut-être
je sais plus comment on commence
s'appelle sur discord salut de détection
voilà c'est ça s'il a de l'enlever en
fait ou le mettre au plus bas possible
c'est sur discord
j'ai l'impression que des fois il te
l'enlève rapidement du coup histoire
d'être vraiment vraiment tranquille
tu as dit qu'il va t'envoyer un
screenshot ouais ne t'inquiète pas
ok parce que parfois il te j'ai
l'impression qu'il passe il passe en
dessous et il coupe un petit peu ok je
vois volume d'entrée et volume de sortie
c'est ça je pense que c'est ça
déterminer automatiquement la
sensibilité d'entrée du micro
je suis sur la bonne page mais si il
m'envoie ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
faire très parfait
il faut peut-être que je le retire
d'ailleurs simplement c'est ça
décocher et mettre en bas dis-lui que il
va t'envoyer
d'accord et mettre en bas
pas moins 100 je sais pas mais la
salaire bien ouais j'ai l'impression que
ça ça a enlevé le petit le petit souci
la dernière fois il y avait pas il y
avait pas ce réglage qui a été je pense
que il s'est mis il s'est mis
automatiquement
arrive à se développer soit
s'il arrive à se développer il va voir
un interventage mais c'est vrai que
ça va vite côté noir
MP3 il va sacrifier avec 38 prise
d'imprimer cette
on peut pas sacrifier
il a du mal à sortir il va aller en deux
mais
je sais pas
l'habitude de voir ce genre de partie
en fait c'était pas ça le réglage qui
allait pas c'est moins 100 c'est un peu
bas ouais il faut que tu relèves un
petit peu
et
il y a peut-être quelqu'un qui va qui va
nous dire d'où ça vient en fait c'est
juste que des fois on te perd un peu de
manière pas normale
on t'entend mais des fois c'est pas il y
a un Ludwig qui t'envoie des trucs sur
WhatsApp regarde regarde ce que Ludwig
fait
[Musique]
mais oui zoom c'est plus c'est plus
pratique
ils disent le mieux c'est moins 40 pour
l'endroit où tu as mis moins 100
en tout cas la position pour le moment
pendant que Baki regarde le screen de
Ludwig elle est
elle est correcte cette fois-ci pour
Wesley on voit que le Fou est un peu
bloqué derrière les pions quand même sur
sur case noire donc malgré la paire de
fou ça se passe
pour les Noirs mais Maxime s'y réussit à
jouer du C4 ou ces trois et à s'activer
il aura c'est lui qui prendra l'avantage
peut-être que les Noirs vont faire C5
ici dans ces cas-là pour essayer de
s'octroyer une case D4 au cas où
peut être une option
après il peut faire tourner
ça perd du temps j'aime pas trop son
coup cavaliers
5 pour jouer sur casse blanche après
mais là juste des Français 6 vous prend
ceci même X3 cavalier F5
il trouve il trouve des bonnes cases
quand même moi j'étais surtout F8 mais
c'est 5 pourquoi pas c'était aussi pas
mal mais
bon mais là pourquoi pas des processus
j'ai du mal avec ce coup qui va mieux
cette
prend ça c'est sûr mais oui moi aussi
j'ai du mal enfin j'aurais c'est même un
coup que j'aurais même pas envisagé en
fait
trois fois quatre
peut-être comme ça ok peut-être sur vous
trois il a x 4
mais est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer un même
C4 ici cavaliers F5 dames C3
on a dame G6 attention il fait froid je
pense que Wesley vous les fous au 4
pour des 5 cavaliers F5 jouer sur les
cases blanches comme ça le fond en D4
moi il est pas mal mais mais il va se
faire chasser on parle cavalier 7
j'ai pas les coups là
c'est il y a beaucoup de possibilités
dans ces positions et Tours 8 c'est un
coup aussi très logique ici il veut
contrôler la colonne bêtement
logique
mais ok sur Foot des quatre il a de 4
donc il attend avant de s'installer
souvent F5 avec le cavalier sont en
carte avec le fou
on peut imaginer qu'après un coup comme
toi derrière maintenant il joue cavalier
F5 web 2 x 4 mais faut hein
direct aussi impossible
direct possible également
en fait ouais c'est celui-là je n'avais
pas du tout une nouvelle fois
6 non
je trouve pas un coup ni de l'un ni de
l'autre
j'ai du mal
le touriste non
si on peut te reverite
mais cavaliers G6 soit j'ai trois ça me
paraît
normal comme coup mais
s'ils le font pas c'est qu'ils doivent
avoir peur que ça ouvre trop les cases
blanches
très clairement mais en tout cas le coup
n'arrive pas attention Maxime qui a plus
qu'une minute
pas facile à jouer là
vraiment pas facile à jouer
surtout que maintenant tu auras 8 c'est
une vraie menace parce que ça peut ouais
ça peut faire mal sur la colonne ça
l'air important pour Maxime
je pense
dame F5 ouais toutes les pièces sur
casse blanche on a vraiment vraiment pas
l'habitude de ça mais là ouais le fou le
3 est pas bon
on a presque envie de le retirer ce pion
F4
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle il y a
pas le coup qui part pour le moment il
échange à je pense que son souffle à qui
j'ai pas j'ai pas la règle du coup de me
prendre des cartes c'était plutôt le roi
blanc qui était en difficulté c'était
Maxime qui était sous pression
et c'est un peu un des travers de Wesley
que ce soit en blitz ou en partie longue
il veut trop assurer
et ça lui coûte d'ailleurs en plus il
fait dame prend des cartes tu reprends
des cartes et il réfléchis dessus donc
c'est vraiment catastrophique
attention il y a pas encore F5 à cause
de tout reprendre 3 mais après un coup
comme Roy F2 on va menacer F5 enfin bon
il y a pas F5
tout quoi que
c'est aussi peut-être un peu mieux pour
les blancs
forcément puisque maintenant on voit ce
pion des cinq c'est lui qui est mal
placé
alors si on peut échanger les tours et
mettre le rond en Descartes tu as déjà
gagnant
de fer H4 là
ça en est loin
normalement on va pas y arriver mais qui
fait plaisir quand même dans cette
partie
le dame prend des quatre j'ai pas un
coup c'est fou
on apprend des cas je pense c'était une
faute simplement
comme une faute à laquelle des fois tu
t'attends à certains coups mais là on
s'y attendait pas du tout ouais mais il
est étonnant le dame prend des quatre
quand même la F5 est tellement logique
en plus il avait plus de temps
et il réfléchit derrière
donc il échange mais il va avoir le
temps de mettre le roi E5
la Tour Eiffel c'était un joli coup un
Maxime qui pouvait pas empêcher j'ai 5
là pour fixer les pions sur les bonnes
couleurs
Wesley qui va réussir à prendre son
demi-point
mais on va voir s'il règle ses problèmes
ouais avec les Blancs
il a pas été impressionnant jusqu'à
maintenant
moi surtout dans la première quand même
mais dans la vie sur la dernière
ouverture
il n'a pas été impressionnant comme tu
le dis c'est bien pour Maxime ça met des
points
il y a du E4 qui va partir pour Wesley
une nouvelle fois c'est ça
qui repart quand même sur la nageoire
enfin là c'est étonnant pour le coup
ouais parce que ça c'est bien passé le
cavalier Sicile alors peut-être qu'il
veut qui veut se donner deux armes un
petit peu variées pour pas laisser
forcément Wesley se rappeler exactement
de ce qu'il faisait c'est vrai que
parfois tu oublies après au fur et à
mesure du match
ouais mais c'est plutôt entre les pauses
qu'il aurait pu faire ça du coup donc je
capte c'est nouveau par rapport à la
première il a peut-être eu ils peuvent
avoir les infos ou pas pendant le match
normalement non oui j'ai pas
l'impression c'est du coup c'est assez
bizarre ouais tu vois il pouvait se
rechanger entre entre après la pause par
exemple après peut-être qu'il a une
petite envie soudaine
si c'est sur le pion des 7 il clique des
6 logique
il se sent peut-être de remettre la
nageur au goût du jour il a vu ce qu'il
y avait sur cavalier C6 peut-être qu'il
ouvre des cartes tu sais j'ouvre une
carte des 6 une carte cavalier C6 et
maintenant il a il a toutes les
informations qui souhaitent
il va pouvoir tout au long du match
choisir ses ouvertures
et là ça semble très très bien pour les
Noirs mais on voit encore qu'il y a
c'est pas si simple de passer
[Musique]
après un coup comme C3 c'est dur de
passer là Maxime veut cavalier C4 vous
prend C4 puis on prend ses quatre
cavalier C1 et C3 par exemple
qui menace quand même quelque chose qui
a validé ces quatre donc j'imagine que
ces trois va être joué pour bloquer
cette diagonale
en tout cas j'ai l'impression qu'il a
quand même pris un petit peu l'avantage
maximum dans ce match déjà il est devant
au score j'ai l'impression qu'il est un
peu au dessus de son adversaire la
dernière partie même si finalement c'est
Wesley qui a eu le petit avantage
pendant un certain moment on a quand
même l'impression que que Maxime est en
maîtrise non
la dernière je trouve qu'elle n'était
pas de super qualité mais ouais mais tu
as pas senti c'est quand même Wesley qui
lâche en premier
quand il a 17 occasion de gagner il va
quand même échanger les dames et
trop mais là Maxime il peut faire la
différence sur celle-là en tout cas
j'aime bien ces coups depuis le début de
la partie là justement c'est ouais c'est
qui ratent les petites occasions pour le
moment quand même plutôt
4 il n'a pas peur d'un Damas 5 ici
quand même l'idée c'est fou prendre des
seins qui est la prise en C3
menace vous prend des soins que des fous
prend ses trois avec le cloche
mais
ouais je suis pas sûr du je suis pas sûr
du pion pour être parce qu'on ouvre
quand même la colonne g c'était pas
c'était pas indispensable
après damassin que c'est joli oh et puis
une minute 30 d'avance quasiment
cavalier 2 là il s'ouvre quand même la
case D3 non il y a pas du qui a validé
le 5 ici
bon
PS4 par exemple
ce qu'il y a moins de pièces c'est avec
moins de pièces le roi blanc il est
quand même plus dur à attaquer tout d'un
coup c'est bizarre j'arrive pas en fait
je suis un petit peu obnubilé par ce roi
blanc et je me demande comment est-ce
qu'on peut le
le matin en quelque sorte
je garde un petit œil parfois sur l'ordi
là je vois qu'il y a un coup qui donne
d'après l'ordi un gros avantage c'est
cavalier E3 je t'annonce que ça va pas
être joué
dans les premiers coups F4 inconnu au
bye
quand même
si l'ordi c'est logique de jouer
maintenant que j'ai 3 ah non il y a ces
trois en l'air bon un coup il y a pas le
temps en fait
[Musique]
attention de pas se rendre des 7 quand
même
mais ça a l'air de passer ouais pour le
moment et maintenant c'est Maxime qui
est mieux
touche les deux colonnes le roi est bien
au centre il peut aller en D8 par
exemple on décède et puis quand même le
problème de ce cavalier qui est un peu
bizarre
surtout j'ai deux il veut quoi dame 4
G 8 et tu reprends B8
j'ai l'impression qu'il veut ça après la
maxime est mieux autant quand même c'est
important aussi
deux trois prochains coups sont chers
ils peuvent faire la différence pour
Maxime
peut-être qu'il va faire juste roi des 8
roi des 7 c'est la même idée
Maxime elle est importante cette colonne
donc avait raison c'était une faute il
donne pas le Punto là
simplement j'ai l'impression
je vois pas comment il veut sauver son
pion à Wesley j'ai l'impression que ça
va ça va augmenter le
tarifs
ça peut être ça peut être dur
damaca3 C7 d'un point à 6 vous prend des
quatre il y a pas de tour prendre des
cartes à cause de la chambre
ça fait un pion de plus mais attention
il y a le roi au centre encore pour
Maxime en 17 et les tours qui sont
braqués dessus
prends des cartes ici
quand même
il faut être précis parce que
Maxime qui doit calculer peut-être vous
prend tout prend tour G2 il fait tomber
un peu risqué
mais bon ça consolide quand même ça
consolide le pion à 6 donc et 4 3 C7 qui
a validé aussi s'il veut froid des 5
puis on prend des seins comme ça
[Musique]
probablement raison quoi que damaka 3c8
il y a pas de tourgiens
un seul coup pour gagner
et c'est hors G2
ici
comme quoi c'est pas
c'est pas le coup le plus dur que Maxime
est trouvé
je pense aussi ça va être gagné assez
facilement ce match
et ton G2 quand j'ai vu que c'était le
seul coup qui gagnait j'étais sûr qu'il
avait trouvé en fait
ça maximie les trouve cela et abandons
instantané sur le comprend aussi et
c'est la pause déjà Baki
c'est déjà la première pause avec trois
et demi qu'on a un an et demi
face la pause aussi dans le chronomètre
il restait combien de temps il reste
j'ai fait sauter le chrono
il restait 40 et une minute je crois
vous dites 40 OK
OK
puisque ça a pas commencé à l'heure
jusqu'à 40 ouais
ça a commencé à l'heure de Wesley
aujourd'hui
à Maxime qui domine
assez face enfin pas facilement mais
assez nettement
ce début de rencontre il a moi il a plus
ses positions ou
[Musique]
voilà la dernière partie elle est jolie
la puce les positions qui maîtrisent ils
réussissent à
là c'est sa meilleure la dernière c'est
sa meilleure partie
et à être très très solide et sérieux et
Wesley qui a raté une petite demi
occasion et qui se fait tout de suite
contrer à la partie d'après
ça va être encore pire dans les est-ce
qu'on a encore des c'est encore 5
minutes la prochaine étape où on passe
directement au 3 0 c'est la mi-temps du
5 minutes
ah oui donc on a mi-temps de 5 minutes
et mi temps de 3-0
ah bah oui
on est pas bien
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr là dans
le match c'est que avec les Noirs Maxim
il va plutôt avoir des bonnes positions
maintenant
ce qui peut choisir les deux dernières
elles se sont très bien passées et même
la première mais il a pas été il a pas
été très heureux quoi sur la première
avec ce cavalier CO2 qui arrivait
donc s'il a aucun problème avec les
noirs qui peut même en gagner ok ça va
être avec les Blancs il va pousser
doucement comme dans comme dans chaque
partie ça va passer assez facile c'est
la deuxième qui est importante
elle a été très importante la deuxième
parce que s'il la perd après ça peut ça
peut vite gamberger
après deux points c'est pas c'est pas
terminé c'est pas comme
Carole sanitaire qui avait rapidement
six sept points d'écart où là il y a
vraiment plus de de risque entre
guillemets
il y a que que
le match est pas plié comme celui d'hier
quoi
hier à 5h30 tu vois tu es bon
même à
ça se voyait le truc c'est que ça se
voit sur les coups quand même
en fait même à 0 0
tu savais
annoncer
il y a un but déjà
ça va être validé
et ben voilà un zèbre commence bien
cette histoire
ça fait plaisir
il faut
je les buts je les buts rien à dire
fantastique un peu comme le tour jet
d'eau de Maxime
après là c'est pas le même enjeu
pour aller essayer de
première équipe depuis 70 ans pas avoir
fait doubler
est-ce qu'il y a vraiment quasiment
comme un gardien de handball
essayer de se jeter
à faire très très mal à nos amis
marocains
j'ai failli pas l'annoncer justement
parce que comme dit le grand grand il
peut y avoir des décalages pour
certaines personnes là je pense que je
suis bien en direct
en tout cas c'est un zéro
mais oui ça peut être compliqué pour le
Maroc parce qu'ils ont une équipe plus
défensive entre guillemets solide
j'ai pas regardé beaucoup de matchs je
peux pas j'ai un peu lu avant pour voir
un peu les enjeux
[Musique]
et je crois que il a leur gros point
fort c'est la défense ils avaient pas
pris de but contre la Belgique le
Portugal et l'Espagne du coup ils
extraient difficile de marquer oui bon
3 minutes de jeu
qui avait passé probablement Griezmann
comme d'hab mais
OK
c'était beau la pause
sur un csc depuis le début de la
compétition tout ça cassé en 5 minutes
ouais mais
difficile l'équipe de France
oh partie interrompu ça fait plaisir tu
sais ce serait moi là je demanderai le
Punto déjà ah mais peut-être qu'ils sont
encore en pub parce que
ça fait plaisir quand même de voir
partir aux quatre cinq
c'est complexe
c'est beau là ça fait plaisir après
cette pause
étonnant
je sais pas ce qu'il fait
il a pas d'électricité non plus
il a pas l'air bien
OK
I
il va peut-être faire cavalier C3 cette
fois
ou tenter un autre des quatre on va voir
aussi
[Musique]
c'est quoi
qui réfléchit
c'est bizarre il a pas du tout le même
setup que d'habitude est-ce qu'il a
déménagé ce qu'il est pas chez ouais je
sais pas
ici en tout cas dans ces premières
parties Wesley
ça peut être un joueur
j'ai relancé OK
peut faire ça peut-être
qu'après
de Maxime sont quand même un peu mieux
placés
c'est quoi le bon coup là pour les Noirs
intéressants là stratégiquement de
trouver le bon coup
des cinq peut-être c'est ça
qu'autre j'aime bien ok
c'est la faute
quand même à chaque fois le coup le plus
le plus serré Wesley
là il veut quoi il veut des cinq
maintenant
c'était quand même tu vois tu peux
essayer de mettre une petite pression
quand même pas j'espère pas essayer mais
un truc ouais un peu plus ambitieux quoi
très serré bizarre
on nous demande pourquoi tour 2 puis
tourin ça c'est
des coups d'ouverture répétez pas c'est
pas c'est pas fait au hasard ou deux
justement pour provoquer B6
mais ouais c'est pas un coup très
logique en soi par contre nous explique
dans le chat merci à peu ce qui nous dit
qu'il a été expliqué en fait sur le
stream US qui joue depuis une
bibliothèque pour avoir une meilleure
connexion à cause d'une tempête de neige
chez lui
d'où le sata un peu bizarre ah ouais
mais ça c'est
clairement handicapant pour Wesley c'est
pour ça qu'on le voit un peu remettre sa
souris
une note un truc sur un papier je sais
ce qu'il faut
[Musique]
pendant la partie ouais en train
d'écrire des trucs je sais pas ce qu'il
faut
pas de chez lui
est-ce que Maxime il peut faire la
différence dans une telle partie c'est
passé quand même très
très solide
il y a des fous un tout petit peu
meilleur au F5 ça donne pas de problème
d'un problème
on sait comment il joue maintenant
c'est hyper solide mais ça doit tenir ça
pour les noirs
sans trop de difficultés
mais ici en fait c'est sur un petit
portable ah ouais mais en fait il a
vraiment
ça rend des conditions de merde
il y a vraiment une tempête de nager
à côté droit j'essaye de regarder un peu
le set up et tout ouais ça a l'air
d'être 14 en fait
il faut prendre
[Musique]
ça a l'air ça a l'air particulier ces
conditions de jeu
tant mieux écoute
mais après je crois qu'il est en dessous
il est sur souris sur un ordi portable
j'ai l'impression tu peux jouer très
vite sur ton ordi portable il y a pas de
Maxime d'ailleurs joue depuis son ordi
portable si j'ai l'impression en tout
cas pas sur un très gros écran donc ça
c'est juste qu'on a l'habitude de le
voir jouer sur cette immense sucre écran
d'habitude de Wesley
t'as pas la rêve de des conditions
sur lequel l'échiquier est minuscule
en fait les chéquiers doit prendre un 8e
de la taille de l'écran ou quoi et les
Ch'tis absolument minuscule
et l'écran est immense et cette fois-ci
du coup on va jouer sur un petit
portable complètement
dans cette finale elle est complètement
égale je sais pas je sais pas ce qui se
passe
pourquoi pourquoi il joue
de l'eau
j'ai 5
c'est pas c'est pas le premier coup qui
vient l'esprit ah bah si j'ai trouvé
cette fois-ci
ça tu t'y attendais pas à Baki non bah
non c'est bien passé la dernière quand
même mais peut-être que ouais il essaye
de faire un coup parti un coup par là
pour
le pour le fatiguer Wesley
ça joue la grande variante
ma pas l'habitude de voir Maxime je la
pétrole il a joué deux fois en il a joué
à sa REACH et
en Autriche là
c'est l'ouverture de
mais c'est sur cette ouverture que
Wesley a perdu contre Christopher Rio là
cette partie incroyable
elle est partie
oh il vient d'avoir une mine de
Giroud sur le sur le poteau désolé mais
là c'était bon quand même c'est pas
l'enduit des zéro incroyable
allez on va y arriver Baky on va y aller
en finale ça va être difficile contre
l'Argentine par contre oh mais je MP3 ok
ça peut faire une belle une belle partie
là aussi c'est exactement ce
contre
plusieurs de toute façon comme beaucoup
de joueurs donc
j'ai pas
longtemps je le trouve lent dans les
ouvertures
qui a joué scrook Évoli H4
anglais
il avait été très bien en Fabiano et
puis finalement
[Musique]
une très grosse partie je sais même pas
si c'est pas celle qu'on avait faite sur
Youtube avec avec Fab d'ailleurs
qui peuvent réfléchir ici mais je
voulais sans [ __ ] c'est très étrange non
surtout que tu as quand même en plus
c'est pas son style du tout tu vois
alors qui peut jouer des petites lignes
essayer de pousser un peu comme Maxime
dans la dans la berlinoise
non là il va pour pour une grande ligne
bizarre il prend du temps en plus
après je pense que oui
en fait tu fais tellement de parties que
c'est dur de souvenirs je me rappelle
bien de la partie ouais
les blancs sont passés par un moment où
ils pouvaient être gagnant et après ça
finit par nul
je suis quasi sûr qu'on l'a fait
ça va pas du tout là ouais
c'est un truc beaucoup plus direct avec
du cavalier C3 du machin et ça jouait
vraiment rien la partie complexe
[Musique]
déjà il y a pas du tout simplement
depuis on prend ces quatre ou duquel
les cases blanches c'est Sébastien qui
doit pas être bien si si regarde
très confiance et qui réussit à mettre
la pression au temps aussi depuis trois
quatre parties
Wesley joue pas dans son style
à contre à contre-courant
ouverture catastrophique de Wesley
choix catastrophique plus même
d'ailleurs
C2
et après c'est de cavalier c'est cette
cavalier dessin s'il arrive à mettre ta
Mercedes pas mal aussi il tape F2
qui est G2 avec
peut-être que ton dmg4 il était un peu
plus précis de ce point de vue là il y a
foi F4 et sur fupron cavalier 3 il tient
la case des 5 donc il a peut-être
presque
ouais mais avec ta dame à manger 4
t'empêcher ça à cause du clos avec tours
F4 c'est vrai aussi mais j'ai le
cavalier il est pas
sûr de rester là ad vitam eternam
G5
qui avait lieu trois
revenez peut-être à temps là évidemment
j'ai 5 ça a l'air très fort
ça a l'air ultra fort
[Musique]
après j'ai 5 et j'ai deux
encore trois minutes il a le temps
d'avance je peux dire ce que dit leur
dit j'ai 5 cavaliers G2 et dames 6
introduire dans le 6
il faut trouver un bon coup
un seul coup pour avantage et c'est tout
réussi voilà
c'est terminé
il y aura
c'est pédagogie sur ce match
westler c'est ouais en fait fallait
absolument faire cavalier au 3 direct je
sais pas pourquoi mais pour rester dans
la partie la queue 3 touches qui a F1
cavalier F4
ça va être trouvé
c'est un peu trop pour Wesley ouais
ouais là c'est trop facile pour Maxime
bibliothèque
[Musique]
il joue pas mal mais il manque il manque
pas mal de choses pour pour rivaliser
avec Maxime ce soir
il fait beaucoup d'erreurs directs il
fait quel F4 Maxime
a l'air pas mal aussi
mais il y a pas gfg froidchamp tourage 6
il y aura toujours
F2 ok ça a l'air gagné
6 contre 30 secondes
ça va mettre le point une nouvelle fois
attention faut pas se relâcher non plus
hein
3,50 à 0-0
après après le problème c'est le temps
aussi pour essayer parce que Maxime
c'était seul coup aussi mais bon après
c'est logique il veut revenir vers 5
d'ailleurs j'ai dit cavalier bien tout à
l'heure mais j'avais
c'est normal d'aller vers le 5 parce que
le point F2 il est bien protégé quand
même par la MCD le tour
tu menaces d'aller en F7 en F3 en fait
tu touches deux cases hyper importantes
de l'échiquier et la 4G 6 ouais tu
toucheras vraiment
faut pas la perdre bah qui se serait con
parce que ça relance dans le match en
fait
un peu à l'instar de la seconde c'est ça
un peu comme la seconde pour notre
faveur en revanche la seconde
mais
la seconde que Wesley aurait pu gagner
qu'il a donné enfin donné
maxime a fini par la gagner allez c'est
bien tourner celle-là faut pas en plus
là c'était vraiment c'est complètement
gagnant et énorme avantage autant là
c'était vraiment point gagner et Maxime
il peut parfois être coupable bah qui de
ces petits relâchement
ouais bizarre c'est pas facile à jouer
là pour les moments
G6 mais j'ai pas l'impression que ça
soit très bon
heureusement la dame 4 c'était c'était
probablement encore faute à cause de
dame G4 seul coup d'âme G4
voilà facile aide
au dernier moment
c'est trop
du match je pense que c'est fin du match
ouais parce que
ça c'est celle là elle aurait pu tourner
côté sceau
c'était un très très joli coup d'Alger 4
ça devrait ça devrait le faire backy
maintenant
et oui parce que les deux parties
chaudes en fait elles sont toutes les
deux tournées en faveur de Maxime
parce que dans celle-là Maxime en fait
il a fait une mini faute il a fait
cavalier F4 au lieu de tournage 6
ok
mais
ça reste minime
alors que Wesley il fait vraiment des
fautes
ouais après peut-être un peu aussi
déstabilisé voilà par les conditions
pas habituelles pour lui mais voilà
c'est comme ça
c'est une très bonne idée en fait de
jouer dans une bibliothèque il devrait
toujours et dans des bibliothèques et
pas chez eux en fait
ouais
ça serait mieux
après en vrai en vrai de vrai de vrai en
soit tout le monde devrait jouer depuis
un endroit autre que chez lui
en soi
ça dans un endroit public ce serait tout
à fait normal donc oui en soi
que tout le monde joue dans une
bibliothèque ce serait complètement
normal ou un lieu affilié ouais mais pas
depuis chez soi
ça c'est quand même
devant du public et tout ça peut être
sympa quoi après
faut payer quoi c'est toujours pareil
c'est French ça va pas être gratuit quoi
c'est 4 c'est un coup typique de la
berlinoise qui tape le pion à 4
et là regarde encore une fois ça se
passe plutôt bien pour Wesley cette
finale de la berlinoise qui est pas si
facile à jouer en blitz toujours
il y a quelqu'un qui lui a demandé de se
décaler
c'est terrible en fait
c'est le cas tu parles dans la vie chute
il a dû déplacer son ordi
ouais non mais c'est
c'est complexe quand même
bien joué il fallait faire quelque chose
puis on prend ici s'il veut cavalier 5
donc mais il laisse [ __ ] F3 GF
je sais pas ça me paraît bizarre quand
même
trois GF je dirais même fou des 6 comme
ça puis on pourrait accepter
peut-être prendre un F3 et prendre en B3
d'abord difficile
difficile pour Maxime
il prend B3 il est cavalier 5
aussi d'ailleurs
qu'il était pas obligé de laisser
cavalier
je sais pas je préférais [ __ ] pour
forcer un peu les événements
ça a l'air dur
c'est très bizarre de pas avoir fait
[ __ ] ou des six et puis on prend le 6
mieux positionnellement et choisir un
truc où c'est un peu le bazar
mais il va peut-être devoir faire ça par
exemple 3 kg 6 roi B7 qui va les prendre
à 4
tu peux dire que
alors apparemment il est très mécontent
du coup il a fait une tête bizarre comme
s'il avait raté quelque chose bon il a
joué le coup main
ouais je sais pas trop c'est un peu
85 64 ans qui suit les orientes bravo
qui allait prendre
ouais en fait
là le problème c'est exactement et ce
qui est en train de se passer c'est que
tu peux faire maintenant cavalier FG 6
mais il va te faire tout reprendre F7 et
en fait il a trio spaunes
apparemment un mec a raison en fait il
tourne l'ordi toi pardon il y a un gars
qui le fait chier dans la bibliothèque
ouais ok
j'ai l'impression
j'arrive pas complètement à voir mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a quelqu'un
qui a un truc qui le gène nettement ok
ça explique un peu les les
déconcentrations en fait
ça c'est dur à jouer quand tu as
il y a des Français qui arrivent dans la
bibliothèque à fait ouais c'est ça il y
a tous les Français qui sont la
bibliothèque dominer sauta le faire
chier en fait
j'ai un gars qui arrive pas de lui
demander si dominerait
c'est dommage j'ai ressenti ouais bon en
fait on en a rien à [ __ ] qui soit
gentil on prend un
devrait
être joué après ça c'est beaucoup mieux
au noir quand même je pense
c'est mieux au noir ouais mais bon après
c'est pas fini
je pense qu'il va faire [ __ ]
après la position est dure là
pour les noirs
solide
il a l'air d'être vraiment au bout de sa
life
tant qu'il reste loin les trioches punch
ok ça va on souffle non mais il va pas
là il va pas y arriver là ouais c'est ça
sent ouais ça va être ça va être un
massacre ce match
en fait
terrible
ok bon j'ai 8 il tente quand même
s'il arrive à jouer à 4 à 3 c'est notre
avantage pour lui mais peut-être un tour
à 4 chez Maxime là
mettre une tour hyper loupe qui bloque
qui bloque le pound donc en plus
tu auras 4 ça a l'air bien
je vois pas trop je vois pas d'autres
couples pour Maxime
j'ai 4 pourquoi pas un intermédiaire
mais bon bizarre
3 maintenant comme menace
on dit qu'il y a encore des crises ou
pas non
non il y a une attaque ah oui merci de
me prévenir
ok c'était chaud et pour nous
juste à côté terrible ok
ce que Maxime va réussir lui aussi à
marquer
ouais ça devient plus si clair bon là le
roi est faible maintenant mais mais
quand même il pousse son Punto quoi
faut prendre qu'il allait F3 roi F2 qui
avait pour 5 %
Lite quand même 22 secondes allez si
Maxime gagne sa life ferme encore plus
il le ferme encore plus
je pense que ça va être trois pions pour
la pièce probablement gagnant pour les
Noirs mais
alors dis donne le problème c'est que
l'ordi donne égalité surtout des 5
taper les plombs ah oui
F7 à 4 ok c'est chaud mais ça va gagner
allez Maxime
ça il a pas l'air d'être
ouais
en fait il veut prendre G5 et pousser
les puntos
[Musique]
a mis la tête tombée Wesley en fait faut
juste qu'il clique ouais faut qu'il
clique Maxime
je pense qu'il tombe
il a joué pour la pendule Maxime
OK
bon c'est déjà bien aussi
en fait il va la gagner
Baki
peut-être
c'est chaud
il prend des quatre
il a pas pris mais il a gagné
ils ont tous les deux de dames en fait
c'est quoi cette cause
il a deux dames Maxime ça fait 6 2
c'est trop en fait là 6 2 c'est déjà un
match quasi pliée
il y arrive pas à Wesley et on aura
c'est normalement ce sera vendredi pour
la peine le match de Maxime contre
magnouche
j'ai tellement de mal à voir wesh les
revenir là plus qu'à déjà
aucune chance pour pour Wesley voile
depuis le début trop d'erreurs trop de
mais déjà normalement un peu plus fort
mais là j'ai l'impression qu'il joue pas
non plus à son meilleur niveau Asley
et ça fait ça fait vraiment beaucoup
trop d'écart
il nous reste quand même deux heures
pour être bien sûr un peu plus bas qui
quand même
deux heures tu serais pas bien sûr je
suis quand même assez désolé avec toi
attention de pas vouloir raccourcir
comme quoi le système des 7 il est quand
même bien cadré
il a fait il a fait un coup bizarre
Maxime on a l'impression qu'il donne une
pièce mais en fait il la récupère tout
de suite
speech c'est beau en fait le nom
on nous repose la question et quand il
accueil c'est quand il cavalier C6 sur
ful prend le 4 il y avait des dessins
jolie tous les trois E4 c'était une idée
de Muret je crois il y a comme Muret
une vingtaine d'années
trentaine d'années et c'était vraiment
beaucoup je sais plus qu'il avait joué
en premier j'avais impressionné tout le
monde et voilà donc il a pas donné une
pièce en
diminuer
[Musique]
c'est quoi c'est un punto de plus encore
pour Maxime pour pas grand chose en fait
là
en fait il va essayer de monter au 3150
là c'est vraiment
à sens unique ce soir Baki
on veut des 7
c'est trop
est-ce que tu connais la date du
prochain content non non l'année
prochaine l'année prochaine on va faire
une petite pause là-bas qui après tout
ces matchs on va faire une pause Express
parce qu'après il y a le championnat du
monde de Blitz c'est rapide dont on va
profiter ça va être super mais on va
garder l'énergie terrestre pour pour
cette fin d'année
ce qui s'est Matthieu qui est toujours
Matthieu qui est champion mais il est
con il est triple champion déjà ou
double champion double champion
un acteur mais c'est terrible il y a
maintenant il y a l'ampoule qui s'allume
et qui s'éteint chez Wesley ouais
et oui il y a plus de lumière chez
Wesley ça et c'est revenu il en peut
plus en fait il est écœuré Wesley
ah dommage qu'il ait la peau
mais il peut il peut faire si ça s'était
encore il peut il peut juste déconnecter
et dire dire range qu'il a plus de
réseau quoi tout simplement en fait
c'est peut-être le mieux pour lui ah
ouais mais là il a encore des problèmes
il y a des gens qui lui parlent à côté
non mais c'est trop
Facebook
non mais bon ok enfin genre au bout d'un
moment c'est
tu peux pas suivre un truc de 4 heures
comme ça enfin genre le gars ne peut
même pas jouer correctement bon il a il
a perdu il est tombé sur plus fort que
lui machin mais ça fait aucun sens en
fait
ok c'est quoi cette partie là
il joue casse blanche Wesley quand même
attention
vous êtes trois alors c'est pas pour
dire parce que je disais ça avant live
on dit que j'avais pris le melon mais
quand tu compares quand même avec
l'organisation d'une backup
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a une petite
différence quand même en termes d'orgas
après j'ai peut-être pris le melon mais
c'est ouais tu demandes qui est tu sais
ça me fait penser à la blague de yossif
il y avait une magnifique blague de
yossive dans une partie entre Glenn et
Joël Lautier
le commentaire de j'ai aussi après 20
coups c'est et après 20 coups je ne sais
pas d'après le texte qui joue le lotier
qui est non c'est Christine
c'était Christine et après 20 coups
après le texte je ne sais pas qui est
Joël lethier ou Christine je pense que
c'est les bons joueurs mais peu importe
et là c'est vrai que après après 1h30 je
ne sais pas quelle est la backup et qui
est le speed chasse qui
vient voir un retour magnifique de d'un
joueur marocain là tu étais pas bien ah
non ils sont ralentis là incroyable
[Musique]
toujours à 0,1 de l'autre côté et ici on
est à 6,2
cases blanches
récupérer 5 mais là juste même tu auras
vite
ouais dur
mais c'est dommage que pour ces tournois
avec beaucoup de prix et puis des
tournois intéressants il joue pas
[Musique]
en réel
Jessie Greenman
comment je peux te spoil
achète-toi une télé frère
mais ouais c'est dommage qu'il joue pas
dans des meilleurs conditions ouais pour
tous ces tournois il y a beaucoup
d'argent c'est dommage
moi après j'avais proposé après j'ai
proposé à chascom de de faire jouer
Maxime depuis la reine avec des
commentaires et tout et de d'essayer de
trouver un système mais ça pas été
accepté
pas de bol
ça aurait pu être très sympa
[Musique]
au bout d'un moment
c'est pas pour 500 balles par jour
c'est un peu dommage quoi pour plusieurs
raisons même pour la mise par rapport à
la mise en scène pour les quitter du
tournoi pour 1000 a raison qu'il faut
qu'il faut le faire
en G6 mais bon ça va pas surtout recette
faut G6 H6
ça barbole quand même côté Maxime quoi
qui peut y avoir du cavaliers F2 avec
des fous des trois et ça joue un peu
quand même
c'est sûr que la diagonale H7 B1 elle
est plus importante que en B3 il fait
pas grand chose
mais tout recettes cavaliers prend des
six peut-être
ok il a raison de réfléchir quand même
Maxime
que une petite peau de banane peut se
poser un peu
n'importe où dans ce genre de poste
il faut pas le laisser revenir pour rien
voilà
ça a été trop vite trop trop n'importe
quoi j'ai l'impression
je veux dire donne complètement foutu
après damage 6 fous prend le 7 foug6
c'est vrai que ça a pas l'air facile
d'éviter mat ça va être sûrement tout
rêve cette forcée mais faut prendre FC
renoncera fujetti
mais là ça a été trop vite et trop j'ai
rien compris j'ai pas eu le temps
ça revient un peu pour Wesley attention
quand même de pas le laisser revenir
bêtement
et puis là il a joué tellement vite il a
encore une minute 30
on suit un peu hein cette fin de match
de l'autre côté aussi il a joué Fuji 6
ah ouais bon il a trouvé ouais mais
après c'était facile
non mais c'est
attention il faut que J6 d'un E3 roi B1
dépend ses deux rois iI faut aussi
s'échappe quand même
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur dame of
Thrones
c'est loin c'est pour ça que je l'ai pas
vu la prochaine la première fois un
couloir mais jolie fougiste
encore une partie sinon il y en aura
plus
dans cette cadence
on espère qu'il va vous faire passer le
temps la maxime
alors faut faire passer le temps là on
veut pas en voir une de plus
en 5 en 5-0 en 5 2 là
j'ai 8 maths
ça va faire 6 3 6
ça c'était une perte pas
si mon temps était juste il y a plus de
partie mais après c'est pas sûr qu'on
entend était juste et ouais il était
juste
c'était une défaite pas obligatoire
celle-là
qui est sorti immédiatement de sa pièce
de bibliothèque
fantastique il va gueuler ouais ouais il
est sorti vraiment énervé ouais il doit
y avoir trop de bruit ça doit être ouais
je sais pas ce qui se passe on sait pas
ce qui se passe dans son truc mais
ça a pas l'air exceptionnel quoi
quand même
c'est pour ça qu'il y a la pause en fait
terrible qui est la mi-temps en même
temps que cette pause Kevin
est-ce que vous êtes beaucoup avec le
double le double écran
je pense ouais mais pas pour le foot
il y a tout le monde qui a l'écran c'est
normal
évidemment
il est sur le double il n'a que le fou
des pH
studi parce que c'est la mi-temps
ah oui vous êtes beaucoup à venir ah oui
vous venez pendant la mi-temps et oui et
c'est la pause je sais pas l'horreur
quoi terrible
non pas nous on n'est pas hyper voilà on
a fait la béca pendant François
Angleterre quand même donc
on était obligé
demi-finale quand même donc oui
je suis un petit peu
[Musique]
je regarde pas je suis même pas le score
parce que je sais que tu me diras si un
but donc je te fais confiance je regarde
vite fait quand je vois des choses se
passait ouais c'est ça c'est pratique
mais on domine du coup ou pas
non non la fin de match elle était il y
a eu deux trois grosses actions
marocaines je crois après je regarde
enfin tu vois je regarde pas vraiment
ouais on a sué à la fin on est d'accord
et retourner fantastique je sais pas de
quel joueur mais qui
trempez la barre
mais bon c'est clair que l'équipe de
France est quand même meilleur en
attaque en défense non
il a fait un retour
première finale les frérot marocain ça
me dérangerait pas qu'il gagne enfin
quand même pas au bout d'un moment
j'ai pas dit qu'on était mauvais en
défense mais on est tellement brillant
en attaque bon
il est quand même particulier le frérot
c'est genre les autres ils ont pas fait
de finale faut les laisser gagner ça va
quoi
fais ta life
j'en sais rien je vois moi j'ai pas vu
que là où le Marocain prend carton jaune
c'est clairement le français qui fait la
faute et qui m'a été j'ai pas vu moi je
peux pas dire
[Musique]
on a trop gagné je préfère perdre mais
arrêtez
c'est trop
il va bien malheureusement à mon avis
ça commence comme ça
non mais il y a eu un super une superbe
frappe de Giroud un moment aussi on
aurait pu être à 2-0 et c'était
fini tôt mais là c'est chaud
il va falloir laisser gagner
Messi en finale aussi pour leur faire
plaisir enfin c'est quoi le délire
qui gagne une coupe du monde mais je
sais pas quoi au bout d'un moment
ils sont quand même impressionnant les
Argentins cette année
personnellement pépon Messi à la fin du
match non mais j'ai pas non au bout d'un
moment non mais je comprends pas en fait
peut-être que Maxime c'est pareil il
devrait peut-être laisser gagner Wesley
parce qu'il a pas de chance de jouer
dans une bibliothèque
bah ouais non mais je sais pas au bout
d'un moment
en première classe direction Buenos
Aires pour aller lécher les Roussos de
Messi mais c'est tellement ça
ce soir on nous pose la question Maxime
il est fort et Wesley
à part la dernière là il faut pas qu'il
refasse comme bizarre
elle fait une bonne partie bon là 6 3 de
toute façon
il a de la chance en plus la petite
pause juste après cette faute
permet de pacter
pouvoir se concentrer
après le gars qui écrivait ça c'était
peut-être un Marocain d'un autre côté
j'espère
normal
ah oui ça se trouve il y a le bouquin de
Kevin dans la bibliothèque il va le
redire plus fort après la pause oui
c'est vrai qu'il y a un danger quand
même
s'il voit un livre rouge et qui l'ouvre
on peut être mal
[Musique]
il y a eu un matelas dans ce dans c'est
la dernière fois qu'il y a eu des maths
encore sur l'échiquier dans aujourd'hui
on a eu le tour
à 4mat bah oui le mode de l'escalier
il est il expliqué le mode de l'escalier
non dans les échecs on avait un dame
prend un jeu de tourage 6 aussi on a vu
deux matchs de l'escalier
il va vérifier ça tout de suite dans
pour gagner aux échecs ça c'est sûr
mais il a le droit d'échauffer aux
caméras sont en balade dans un sample
plein d'ordinateur
Maxime aussi en fait on le voit plus
quoi
on a combien de temps de pause là c'est
quoi cette pause de 10 minutes
c'est bien
mais c'est pourquoi il met 10 minutes de
pause sur
trois quatre minutes d'interview pour
écouter un peu ce que Gotham pensait du
match parce que sans l'expertise de
Gotham sur le match je pense qu'on avait
du mal à suivre la suite et après 6
minutes de pause ouais depuis
et toi tu as pas mettre sur chaise comme
à faire la personne de venant mettre
j'en ai pas enfin qu'est-ce qu'on s'en
fout
ouais 10 minutes on est heureux au
tournoi de 960 c'était une heure entre
deux game presque c'est vrai aussi
c'était beau
mais c'est pas une balle perdue c'est
sérieux en fait il y a vraiment une
expertise de Gotham
c'est beau
je suis un petit peu le foot aussi
swaggadique
je l'ai pas encore ma ps5 83
je crois qu'il y avait pas encore partie
pour
enfin tu vas jamais la recevoir c'est
range qui va l'intercepter
mais bon c'est possible de faire
plusieurs choses à la fois
le foot les échecs certains ont d'autres
choses Arnaud qui dit je suis meilleur
au foot qu'aux échecs ça ne témoigne pas
forcément d'un grand niveau foot Arnaud
malheureusement
ça veut pas dire grand chose sur ton
niveau footballistique
il suffit que tu réussis à taper dans le
ballon c'est déjà meilleur
c'est pas bien là
[Musique]
non mais Marno il est sur une dernière
victoire en partie et en partie
officielle c'est officiel
il est pas bien
il faut vraiment que tu passes tactique
à fond il a fait 75 jongles une fois ça
va c'est pas mal
moi je suis à peine meilleur au foot que
donc peut-être même pierre Carnot quoi
dans ces deux sports
on peut plus facilement
il y a des atouts
c'est pas que de la technique au tennis
c'est quand même toucher un peu la
raquette quoi en fait tu peux courir tu
peux défendre enfin voilà
tu es défenseur en fait tu tapes dans le
dos tu mets des coups de genoux dans le
coccyx
j'ai joué au foot pendant 3-4 ans
et ça tu as fait combien de combien de
blessés
en fait c'est à cause de toi qu'ils ont
introduit les 600 les 6 changements
ok ça repart en trois plus une allez on
va voir
ouais non mais au foot ok tu peux tu
peux cacher tes faiblesses
les cartons les cartons n'existaient pas
avant Pâques
bon donc il rejoue tous deux et en fait
où elle l'idée c'est que si tu joues
tout Revin il y a cavalier 8 je crois je
sais plus mais après B6 ok il revient en
main on est content d'avoir provoqué B6
ça rejoue la même position que tout à
l'heure il
est pas bien
quoi ça répète
ça rejoue la même finale non
mais là bon
déjà c'est bizarre que Wesley tombe pas
de dessin
là il arrive pas à faire tenir un truc
qui tombe ah ouais c'est ça deuxième
caméra du coup il a il a même pas
regardé les filles qui est encore
ça y comment ça se concentrer sur la
game
ils sont fous de la partie quoi il
clique totalement au hasard
[Musique]
je comprends pas en fait
il va être obligé de jouer ceci un jour
de toute façon pour jouer sur 8
il va décaler sa caméra sur une chaîne
ah ouais non c'est
parti elle a pas encore regardé en fait
Maxime juste il le voit pas mais
Maxime il est tout concentré mais là où
c'est il a pas encore regardé les chic
et quoi
complètement
c'est juste que il joue depuis un
il a dû il a dû partir un jeu depuis une
bibliothèque pour expliquer pour ceux
qui sont arrivés et qui comprennent pas
donc il est pas sur
sur son setup habituel et il a des
problèmes
divers et variés depuis tout à l'heure
et donc là si on a un nouveau d'une
caméra qui tombe et qui essaye de
rebrancher je sais pas ce qu'il fait
alors là il s'est concentré il est dans
la veille ici dans la partie il a
empêché le matin Maxime qui attaqué avec
le fou des trois dommage 7 et l'Anam H3
le pion H7 donc il a joué G6
sécuriser cette case et après faut
acheter j'imagine juste fou G7 mais il
peut aussi jouer de la D8 avec l'idée
d'un D7
il peut il peut pas jouer tout revu
l'idée 5
qui tape la case F1 Maxime je te
retrouve mais bon maintenant on reprend
3 et c'est nul tout de suite bien jouer
tour 8
c'était le seul avantage des blancs la
colonne ne
attends il y a un père inscription à 6
encore en l'air à la fin
pas encore faire n'importe quoi
il dit qu'il y a fou prends des quatre
c'est joli très dur à voir
mais ce qui peut pas jouer simplement
damso
si si mais genre fous prends des cas tu
joues pour avantage
faut prendre des quatre ou prend F8 faut
prendre 3 puis on prend le 3 et il a
joué en plus
il joue un minimum quand même ouais je
sais pas et 5 il a un petit peu
mieux noir mais bon c'est complètement
nul non
ouais c'est pas si agréable ouais c'est
un peu chiant
[Musique]
il va faire réussir
bah oui mais bon
visez la nulle ça lui fait pas peur
alors kssis on l'a vu tout à l'heure
s'il faut prendre 4 des 5 fous des trois
ou quatre
que vous pouvez retrouver dans une vidéo
de Vlad elle s'est retrouvé ça je sais
plus laquelle malheureusement
alors ça répète la dernière partie où il
était complètement foutu
avant
et Maxime il avait pas joué cavalier
Descartes
tous les deux ils sont préparés entre
les rondes
j'aimerais bien que Maxime revienne sur
un âge d'or quand même c'est un peu plus
marrant
après il a pour gagner un backi
quand même plus drôle à regarder là
moi ça aussi mais c'est plus enfin je
sais pas les il y a moins de pièces
c'est plus direct
dangereux en plus
en 3 + 1
il s'est passé un truc là qu'est-ce qui
se passe qu'est-ce qui nous a fait
Kilian là oh il était pas loin
c'est quand même tu la tour elle est
mieux en un quand elle est moins bien
connectée mais il va jouer tour aux deux
c'est le sale coup non sauf si tente de
faire marcher un C3 mais ces trois puis
on prend ces trois cavaliers G5 on a du
mal à y croire
je tourne un peu lent pour jouer ce tour
au deux mais
prends H4
bien jouer 4
[Musique]
il y a pas
j'ai quatre ça me prend j'ai 4 ça me
prend 4 cavaliers F6 puis on prend tout
reprend
F7 un truc comme ça c'est moi
attention les dames prof 7 il marche pas
trop parce qu'il faut être fuite
derrière j'ai pensé justement dans cette
position sans le cavalier en 4 donc il
fait le tour prend des quatre
dames quand dame prend G4 cavalier F6
puis on prend F6 tu reprends G4 trois H8
vous prend F7 tours B4
après tu es même pas obligé de jouer fou
des trois c'est peut-être un peu mieux
pour le blanc ou G3 mais du coup tu en
prends des cartes c'est bien joué non tu
reprends des quatre c'est bien joué
il y a pas de machin tourner
c'est ce que j'avais
de temps en temps
si tu fais un coup genre comme A5 bon
qui est con mais il y a dame prend effet
mais il y a peut-être des G3
qui peuvent attaquer
d'être revenu avec d'autres ambitions
dans ce 3+1 il a bien joué la première
il y avait des machins
ok bon Maxime qui risque pas grand chose
il y a peut-être dmgk il va peut-être
jouer dame G4 il va mettre la
attention de pas se prendre après un
tour G3 tours géant
ok waouh ça a été vu tellement vite ça
ouais
les deux
OK et ça ça donne quoi
moi je prendrai les blancs quand même
ici Baky je préférais cette roi
parce que 8 mais j'aurais peur de dame 4
quand même ouais
ok ouais j'ai compris après mais bon
très dur à voir
[Musique]
il peut pas faire juste un H6
dame 6 roadh8 cavalier F7 37
[Musique]
ça marche pas
il y a pas de 4 tu fais G6 c'est ça
ouais je suppose
ça a l'air d'aller pour maximum un peu
de bol mais ça passe
pour B8 Dame des cinq faut prendre
il peut être il peut être vite mieux à
Maxime
ça tourne bien là
il peut même jouer fou G7
barbelé comme ça enfin tu reprends mes
deux rois c'est un fougères je pense
qu'il va la gagner ça a l'air de très
très bientôt tourner Baki avec un petit
peu de chance quand même
un peu de balle sur Salah ouais mais
c'est important ils font en avoir
là
mais ouais c'est qui joue mieux là sur
cette deuxième partie de match attention
donc il y a pas tout revu échec
elle est pas encore gagnée soit dit en
passant je préférais
c'est compliqué
allez il faut réussir à faire quelque
chose de bien aller bouffer Punto H3
mais je pense pas qu'il y arrive
après les Blancs ont du mal à avancer
non
parce que si tu pousses le pion B tu vas
être faible
cavalier B6 un roi de Wesley il va le
faire maintenant Maxime la forcer il va
mettre le pion c'est 3 j'imagine
ouais c'est qu'il y a peu de temps et il
va peut-être faire ce bibliothécade
parce que ça a pas l'air confortable là
où il est
et Maxime qui joue vite mais il perd à 6
mais là il se fait bibliothèque
peut-être allez Maxime faut juste clique
là faut jouer sur la bibliothèque
pour le moment
voilà il est complètement gagnant
maintenant et le pion qui va arriver en
B5 et c'était pas loin attention quand
même hein
le niveau de jeu il est remonté un côté
côté saut là il joue plus à quelque
chose qui ressemble à du saut quoi
après il a fait une très bonne partie
mais ça ressemble le plus à quoi on
s'attendait pour le match d'aujourd'hui
Maxime qui rejoue cette variante mais
faut l'arrêter ça devient
c'est étonnant surtout que sauf vient de
faire nul dans cette variante sans même
pouvoir regarder l'ordinateur
et c'est toujours la même position
c'était D6 bacs qui on est bien d'accord
on vient de faire fouter 5 il a rien
obtenu
si elle était un petit peu mieux je
pense au début mais
ouais là il va regarder il va jouer
il a été quoi il avait fait à 6
ouais c'est ça
regarder l'écran je vais pas faire mieux
en regardant
il repart sur la même
je sais pas comme ça ça me va il y a un
truc qui va pas dans la position noire
mais
qui me diras
faut prendre B2
Maxime rejoue
comme ça il n'a pas été heureux quand
même sur la dernière partie il a pas eu
de bol après faut qu'ils prennent ça
avec philosophie il avait plutôt le
circonstances de son côté jusqu'à
maintenant là ça c'est un peu retourné
faut pas
dans le mauvais sens
les deux parties où c'est tombé dans le
bon sens là c'est la première qui tombe
vraiment mal
c'est un petit peu mieux parce que
finalement la prochaine partie là ça va
être nul et la prochaine ça joue quand
même quelque chose
on a vu qu'il jouait à
on a vu qu'il pouvait jouer vite Wesley
faire attention il est capable de
cliquer quand même malgré
j'ai l'impression qu'il est un peu réglé
ces conditions de jeu il a peut-être
réussi à faire du silence autour de lui
parce qu'il a
il a remis ces trucs bien en place quand
il arrivait et depuis là quand même
l'air de jouer nettement mieux hein
regardez la menace la menace C6 vous
bougez fou B3 qui gagne l'OPI en 4 ce
serait incroyable
ça y est encore une merde à côté
non
bien joué sur fullet 3 il veut revenir
sous B5 et sur C6 maintenant il joue
fous ces deux ça va répéter là faut B3
faut baisser 5 ou des 5 plus de 3
je pense pas que Wesley puisse jouer
pour quoi que
non je pense pas mais il peut peut-être
jouer avec ces cinq un peu plus tard par
exemple F5
après je vois aussi plus tard jouer pour
CS5 c'est vrai que le pion à 4 il n'y a
pas terrible mais je pense qu'il va
prendre la nulle là
j'arrive jamais à comprendre son
attitude ces fois il tente pas des trucs
et des fois il tente aléatoirement tu
sais jamais vraiment
mais c'est quand même un poil plus
agréable pour lui
il a pas joué du tout non plus quoi
c'est l'avantage aux échecs il y a pas
d'arbitre là en fait
ça s'énerve au niveau de l'arbitrage
dans le chat
il se passe quelque chose
j'ai vu plusieurs fois qu'il y a la
terre mais c'est tout
on sera pas plus baquis
les rois des trois nan ça joue bien la
côté
600 qui menacent mais c'est quoi ce
niveau
C4 le bon moment c'était peut-être le
dernier dernier moment de jouer ces
quatre parce que maintenant sur plus on
prend il y a fou français
ok un poil désagréable
tu peux faire ces 6 quand même échanger
ces 6 contre ces quatre
HC si laisse passer 5 là il peut pas
jouer C5 Maxime est-ce que c'est pas
Maxime qui va jouer pour gagner après
ces cinq maintenant
pierre Fouday 8 après
ouais mais tu joues clairement plus pour
avancer
ça devrait faire nul
[Musique]
terrible bizarre la réflexion de Maxime
là pour moi c'est ces 5 tempo ici
c'est là que tu gagnes ton pain
alors dis adore ces 6 hein faut prendre
ces 6 des Français 4
ni de l'autre
il a je sais pas pourquoi c'est 5
peut-être mais ça faut faire gaffe parce
que si tu fous le pion en
si tu fais G3 H5 H4 H3 après tu bloques
tout sur case noire
moi j'en ai perdu une contre
de ce style là mais bon après je l'avais
je l'avais un peu dans dans le fion des
deux côtés
les pions comme ça des deux côtés
attention qui est pas un B5 qui partent
qui puisse partir un moment moi ça me
fait toujours peur ces trucs là juste
pour expliquer parce que si les Noirs
font un moment donné fous prend qu'on va
faire pion prend qui font G3 qu'on fait
puis on prend ils ont H2 à la fin là le
fou va venir en B2 peut-être fou E4 et
jouer C5 pour ouvrir la position à un
moment tu vois par exemple si je C5 là
c'est déjà pas facile parce que faut 3
puis on prend des quatre il faut prendre
des quatre fou c'est 5
c'est dur c'est simple maintenant puis
on prend rouapranf ou des cadeaux
[Musique]
comme ça
c'est vraiment un coup de bol là
jouer encore mais là peut-être
Forza 4 et fousser 4 tours
Maxime qui échange
ouais mais bon là ça c'est nul facile
ouais c'est quand même Wesley là qui
dominant depuis quelques parties mais
attention attention
c'est là qui nous veut le coup qui nous
embête tant
allez il faut que Maxime réussisse à
faire une bonne game là même si c'est
encore nul c'est pas grave
remontada de soi attention ouais ouais
attention parce que
parce que son niveau de jeu était
peut-être lié dans le dans le premier
dans la première portion à des problèmes
un peu extérieures et peut-être que du
coup ça altéré notre jugement bah qui de
ce que valait vraiment saut dans ce
match
en tout cas depuis quelques parties là
il fait peur
de montrer c'est tout
c'est exactement le type de combat qu'on
attendait alors Maxime peut répondre à
ce combat mais mais c'est sûr que pour
lui ça peut-être été un peu
déstabilisant au début parce que tu dis
c'est bon je maîtrise le match c'est
tranquille et tout d'un coup c'est
finalement
permis à osser de se remettre dans le
match c'est pas celle qui a été décisive
d'un point de vue de de dynamique mais
c'est celle qui a permis à Wesley de
revenir au score quoi
ça fait une minute qui tombe sur cette
position
étant complètement là ouais ah peut-être
un problème de connexion parce qu'il
bouge plus du tout
ni sur une cam ni sur l'autre
alors il a joué mais les caméras sont
figées
j'en sais rien
mais il y a quelqu'un qui lui parle à
côté clairement il y a encore des
problèmes pour lui
il est vraiment ouais mais il est dans
des conditions de jeux qui sont
qui sont extrêmement difficiles pour
Wesley
mais il y a eu il y a un bug bizarre
il y a vraiment des gens qui viennent
lui parler
c'est trop
c'est quasiment impossible de jouer
quand c'est comme ça à ce niveau là je
veux dire c'est pas possible
ça demande trop de concentration
puis c'est pas une fois pendant 4 heures
en fait c'est une fois tout les toutes
les deux parties je vais les quatre là
d'ailleurs
il a gaffe immédiatement en fait
bien joué
ment mais c'est
pas dans tout le match
OK
attends c'est pas si clair ici
sur le problème c'est que faut prendre
G7 qui va les prendre il faut prendre un
et se roi pranget
incavelier de 3 il y aurait Dame des
quatre
alors il peut peut-être y avoir un
damasat échec intermédiaire
tu vois qui a essayé
trois
donc ça peut être un bon coup c'est pour
ça qu'il réfléchit un maximum
j'avais pas du tout j'ai eu après
j'avais pas d'âme des catchec ok
aujourd'hui je suis un peu donc ça veut
dire que KSC de fouger 7 rois ranger 7
je pense c'est mieux pour les Noirs déjà
mais c'est pas qualité de plus quand tu
la perds pas cette cale
après tu peux peut-être
ah non mais l'ordi vous êtes tout rêve 2
sur damaset
j'ai regardé après
[Musique]
gagnant pour les noirs
tu prends la colonne
et Maxime qui a bien bien profité là de
du petit temps de flottement de Wesley
ouais mais il a très bien joué au
maximum ces derniers
il a profité du temps de flottement quoi
une erreur et voilà c'est une dame
ça peut être la fin du match ça
ouais bah il a perdu une minute sur
cavalier de D2 déjà donc
gestion du temps qui a pas été bonne
c'est grosse gaffe après il était foutu
je pense que Maxime gagnait dans tous
les cas cette partie c'est quand même
plaisir le petit cavalier
mais ça fait du bien
mon petit cavalier au 3
6 ouais
bizarre mais moi je connais pas du tout
alors je peux pas te voilà je sais
bizarre pourquoi
je peux pas vous aiguiller
et est-ce qu'on peut utiliser les cases
blanches je ne sais pas moi qui
c'est comme un peu une perte de tempo
comme le pion mélanger deux mais
bon
quoi ça pas grand intérêt non ici
[Musique]
je sais pas trop je sais pas trop quoi
dire sur cette position j'ai
je sais pas ce qui se passe là Kevin
c'est pas si on peut être mieux je pense
pas qu'il soit mieux en fait avec le nom
et j'ai du mal à comprendre je sais ça
m'arrêter très logique il faut ces
quatre fois aussi mais du mal à savoir
comment prendre l'avantage on doit
pouvoir mais je sais pas
en tout cas c'est solide maintenant pour
essayer il est vraiment bien en place
ouais si tu arrives à stabiliser ça va
pour les noirs et le pion aussi s'il est
pas mal il tient la case des seins qui
est la colonel est ouverte pour la tour
donc ces pions doublé dans le centre il
contrôle beaucoup de cases c'est pas pas
vraiment une faiblesse
quasiment 0,9 après cavalier B6
ça arrive vite en C4 c'est vrai que
c'est visuel après si le cavalier
débarque en C4 il va faire mal
ouais même un coup comme dessin qu'un
c'est pas très agréable non plus de si
si
donc
c'est pas un coup difficile en soi
blague de mauvais goût dans le chat
ouais ça c'était un son sobriquet
préparer en amont
non c'était pas facile après C4 là il y
avait plus on prend pour prendre dame B7
mais tour BK
c'est un peu étonnant quoi
ça craque dans le chat
ça craque totalement
il va faire quoi il va faire dessin OK
mais il décale son cavalier le 3 il
était pas terrible en G3 c'est bien ça
va mieux la côté
non là c'est la stabilise bien peut-être
à 5 ouais pour attaquer de l'autre côté
pour Wesley
ces trois m'ont maximal stabilisent
après il est pas mieux
ouais mais c'est peut-être plus facile à
jouer maintenant à quoique
il se dépêche de d'échanger que je suis
pas hyper fan de ça je vois
ça va changer une paire de cheveux
c'était intéressant comme original de la
part de Wesley et maintenant le cavalier
qui va devoir repartir et sur cavalier 3
fois 6 mais bon tu vas à quoi tu vas en
H2 du coup non il va quand même en E3
quand il est pas dérangé par des gens
qui lui parlent pendant les Games c'est
quand même pas la même la même limonade
c'est extrêmement solide
non après c'est pas facile avancer par
exemple si il fait un G5 Maxime peut
jouer G4
et on y va peut-être pas la gagner mais
je vais faire ça ressemble plus à des
parties entre guillemets normal quoi
pour Wesley il replace les tours
26 secondes contre 24
j'ai été déconnecté
attention aussi au sacrifice de qualité
qui peuvent arriver à laisser bien la
Wesley se met mal au temps
Maxime qui réussit à faire une diff
une grande partie
solide sur les appuis Maxime
c'est Wesley qui donne tout pour pour
gagner mais maximum contre
pour deux dames C4 elle prend pas le
pion c'est 3 pour le moment encore
mais tout rêve 7 tours c'est 7
maintenant qui arrive Maxime sous
pression
des deux ouais il faut faire tomber ici
allez ciao
il va se faire peut-être pénétrer Colona
allez c'est pas mal il a le temps de
faire tour à deux
et tout à 5 très bien joué de la part de
Maxime ouais c'est qui a raté une énorme
opportunité un tour à 7 qui semble être
vraiment fort
qui a été raté et maintenant Maxime
réussit à se débarrasser d'une tour et
va pouvoir tenir
le demi-point on espère en tout cas ce
qui est encore des coups de butoir qui
arrive à gauche à droite bah qui le
dessine co qui est parti on va continuer
à jouer le gain ou pas oui
allez cette fois-ci ça va probablement
faire nul
ouais
il est obligé de prendre nul en trois
points d'écart toujours à la ça va faire
petite pause normalement bah qui est
important et oui
il y a encore du 3 1 ah bah oui encore
une petite 25 minutes derrière
bon c'est important là c'est 10 minutes
de pause
du bien elles font du bien c'est 10
minutes elles font souffler
ouais mais ça arrive un meilleur moment
que tout à l'heure je sais ce que va les
faire Maxime là
il va aller jeter un petit œil
comment le match du coup pour faire un
petit point pour ceux qui regardent que
les échecs comme nous
bah oui
un zéro
mais qui domine maintenant
c'est Wesley
le Maroc il eut très bien
on demande qui domine
la France repose rien ok
ce qui regarde que les échecs n'ont pas
forcément envie de savoir ce qui se
passe dans le match de foot bah ouais
généralement nous on a envie de savoir
là c'est on a 5 minutes de pause
vous saurez tout simple
que tu as envie de savoir ou pas en fait
c'est un peu ça le concept
mais toi en plus tu as allumé moi j'ai
pas la télé j'ai rien en fait
moi je l'ai mise quand même
moi j'ai rien vu quoi je rate tout
je vais même louper dimanche
et c'est pendant le foot
non mais vraiment ça
c'est 20h le match la fin
[Musique]
je sais pas si je serai rentré peut-être
la finale
[Musique]
je vais quand même la regarder un petit
peu mais si tu veux
un dans une salle de spectacle
ça va être complexe la salle de
spectacle
moi j'ai mis du coup aussi deux secondes
il reste encore 20 minutes de match en
gros parce qu'il va y avoir les arrêts
de jeu qui vont en mettre encore 7
minutes
qui est pas bien non plus oui le
concours de chant pendant la finale 2018
c'est bon
la personne qui va
ça peut être la dernière action là
de quoi tu parles avec la dernière
action tu me fais peur voilà
je crois que c'est fini
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué
ah oui ça fait plaisir
il y a pas de hors-jeu il y a rien
la pose bien placée
d'accord
ouais mais qui est-ce qui fait l'action
là c'est Kilian non c'est pas
c'est pas Griezmann qui qui fait un
décalage de folie
on va pouvoir se concentrer pour le
match de Maxime c'est beau quand même
l'action
il y a pas de
[Musique]
je vois tout le monde
on va tout gagner aujourd'hui
on a su hier
bah voilà une petite finale de Coupe du
monde
ça va être chaud par contre contre
l'Argentine ça va être très très chaud
incroyable à part ce premier match là
n'hésitez pas si mauvais l'Arabie
Saoudite en fait quand tu regardes les
matchs d'après
ok
c'est un beau match 2018 en Argentine
ouais ça a été vite quand même c'est
beau mais pas très tendu non on était
vite
été
tellement bon en défense aussi
qui était mieux si tu as un zéro c'est
fini quasiment
je trouve qu'on est moins
je regarde pas beaucoup mais
on était vraiment très bon partout 2018
on avait moins de blessés aussi
et ils font quoi là ça va repartir ou je
sais pas il manque une cam pour ça je
sais pas c'est le bordel
en fait
faut pas juste déco une ou deux parties
il faut des côtes tout le match là
Maxime qui peut se régaler en belette
il peut prendre tous les coups
tout à l'heure avec toi en fait
wesh c'est chaud
on sait pas si si on préférait être dans
la position de Wesley
dans la position de
l'équipe du Maroc là qui a le plus de
chance de revenir pas facile
et Maxime c'est vendredi 17h c'est ça
kevinci il a gagné
je pense à vendredi 19h mais je suis pas
sûr je crois que demain c'est 15 heures
ok ça repart allez le déco trop de
Wesley une Grunfeld
allez c'est la première ça sera
peut-être la plus importante
trois points
d'écart c'est beaucoup
tout autre chose qu'une victoire pour
Wesley c'est quasiment fin du match je
pense
alors cavalier prend des 5 je crois que
c'est 5 le coup donc il donne pas un
pion Maxime là c'est tout théorique
qui joue fougères 5 provoque cavalier 4
pour revenir en F4
mais bon ça c'est des détails théoriques
dure à expliquer ils disent que ce sera
vendredi 19 h
donc toi tu seras pas là pour
non pour le match non je suis en voiture
je pense pas en voiture tu travers du
côté de Montpellier c'est ça mais tu
suivras
un petit peu en fait tu vas tout rater
j'espère que je vais pas louper Victor
ça serait difficile voilà cette partie
ça a l'air de pas trop mal se passer
pour Maxime
peut-être symboliquement mieux pour les
blancs mais même pas
attention il y a deux trois coups là qui
vont être qui sont importants un peu une
meilleure structure quand même pour pour
les blancs
et la tour qui contient un échange comme
semble tour qui est
développée automatiquement sans bouger
voilà ça fait plaisir ça rend vitail
je vais couper la canne 2 minutes je
ravitaille rapidement
bon appétit après fou des trois ça m'a
l'air assez facile
il y a pas même un coup comme qui a
validé ses seins il peut y avoir de
cavalier C5 côté Maxime
moi j'aime moins bien que je trouvais
que c'était un joli coup
ok là le roi blanc il est quand même
bien dans le centre ça donne un très
léger avantage
il y a rien non
ouais mais bon
tu vois tu peux pas te permettre
d'échanger toutes les tours tout ça
après il y a pas grand chose
c'est vrai que le roi noir et une belle
case en F6 en plus tranquille
en fait
du coup tu nous dis c'est toi
spécialiste de belette tu dis c'est
Maxime qui a l'avantage quoi tu dis
spécialiste
c'est pas moi
j'aime bien jouer on veut ton expertise
[Musique]
et comme il a bien joué qu'on tenait pas
je pense que et puis les conditions de
jeu il est énorme
ouais donc on est quand même tranquille
s'il tourne à plus de plus 3 c'est bon
quoi
on est assez tranquille maintenant sur
ce match
ça va tenir très tranquille pour Maxime
de se refuser ce luxe
qui va regarder leur match à Maxime et
Magnus
il a du bon côté en tout cas Nico qui
est marrant c'est qu'il est favori
contre Maxime mais il est pas du tout
favori contre Magnus
le temps de prendre des rendez-vous
en plus c'est la même un pion plus plus
éloigné
par exemple C5 puis en français 5e
français 5 et français 5 pions penser 5
ce serait une finale de gagnant pour les
noirs
[Musique]
sans les cavaliers ça c'est gagnant
même si c'est plutôt nul si c'est
le noir peuvent avoir des espoirs de
guerre ici
bizarre qu'il ait changé ses tours qu'il
est pas voulu faire nul tout de suite où
est-ce que très étonnant
ok roi C3 bien joué quand même
pouvoir faire mieux assez facilement
mais bon il y avait aucun sens de pas
prendre la lune tout de suite
en plus ça lui fait perdre du temps
OK
il y a peut-être un
un ok il a de la chance
roi des trois rois B6 3 4
une prise ouais
il était pas à l'heure donc à ce projet
5 si ça ça fait nul c'est un coup de
balle
ça fait 0 0
ça fait nul mais football parce que
tu donnes une pièce quand même
mais cavaliers 5 je prends H6 oui c'est
mieux à la limite
Maxime qui prend pas de risque
OK
ça veut dire qu'il est pas bien
une petite rose ça fait plaisir
mais je vois pas comment il pourrait
remonter dans le match à Wesley
Maxime trop fort
allez on joue sur les cases noires
de voir de nous voir donner les fous
comme l'a fait la maxime dans cette
partie mais
si il arrive à échanger les fautes case
noire il va voir un bel avantage
après il a pas donné le fou pour rien il
a détruit la structure adverse
et là il joue sur case noire il va
essayer de taper sur case noire
enfin il a détruit il a pas vraiment
détruit
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça
pourquoi il faut prendre ce 7 pourquoi
il a fait
en tout cas il a fait vite c'est
tellement vite j'étais surpris il savait
ce qu'il faisait
bizarre je trouve les trois quatre
derniers coups de Maxime bizarre
totalement
de pas laisser
j'aime pas trop laisser des points
gratuits quoi c'est pas trop perdre qui
me dérange c'est donner des parties
c'est bizarre parce qu'il a 2 minutes il
a plus de 2 minutes il était dans une
position tranquille et puis il a
complètement ouvert la position pour les
fous quoi
il y a pas d'un projet 6
je sais pas
ans que moi que puis on prend des quatre
d'un projet 6 mais
[Musique]
bon juste un peu mieux pour les Noirs là
quand même
partie très bizarre des deux côtés mais
peut-être que le match qui a valu ici
cette
donner une pièce
difficile là pour pour Maxime mais
attention parce qu'après ça revient à
deux points et quand tu as deux points
tu es nouveau à portée de fusil
ouais mais après il y a des cases là
quand même je pense que il peut
cavaliers tu vois il trouve un truc
intéressant il va vers des cinq bien
joué mais ça va là pour Maxime je faut
pas qu'il fasse n'importe quoi
j'aime bien
voilà il y a la case de 6 maintenant
c'est ouverte
donc j'ai trois ouais là il a fait une
série de beaucoup maximum
mais bien joué de la part de saut aussi
près d'un cavalier 4 comme fort
c'était pas trouvable cavalier 4
non mais ça ça va aussi
position est pas claire
parce que si un des échanges de dames ça
va être mieux pour les Noirs mais par
contre le roi G7 il est un peu
il est pas super bien
[Musique]
sur blanc il fait un genre de
de mur pour prendre des uns après qui va
aller au 3
attend des gens qui envoient des genres
de mini feu d'artifice pas loin de chez
moi
ça a sifflé la fin du temps
réglementaire
ça va siffler là il y a de zéro il y a 6
minutes
qui font sauter des trucs
ça déstabilise un peu la structure et ça
va ça empêchera dans le futur les noirs
de pouvoir jouer un F5 F4 par exemple
et ça y est on nous annonce c'est fini
pourquoi ça j'entendais des bruits un
peu bizarres autour de chez moi
là aussi ça va bientôt signer la nul
pas sûr
tu préfères les blancs
non là je préfère les noirs
et un cavalier en 4 par exemple c'est
fini
c'est plus beau que France Croatie
après ça aurait été plus facile
attention quand même il y a beaucoup de
pions sur blanc
par tous les bruits autour de chez lui
aussi
ah oui surtout que Maxime vu où il
habite il peut y en avoir beaucoup des
bruits
après ça devrait se calmer non donc il
repart sur 5 là alors qu'il avait joué
qui avait G4 tout le tournoi bon il part
sur E5 il change à chaque fois
allez joue ma partie contre au ski il
avait joué contre les vols simcafield
des flammes illuminées les murs de
Maxime à un moment donné
dans la position elle est encore
théorique non la Bâtie
c'est pas ouais
ça ressemble un peu à ma partie en title
non
c'est devenu théorique si tu as joué un
title c'est devenu théorique après ta
partie
qu'est-ce que c'est facile à jouer en
blé
[Musique]
en fait des deux côtés
attention ce genre de pause
sur G4 je pense qu'il fallait prendre en
G3 quand même
[Musique]
j'aime pas trop ce qui s'est passé
après ça a l'air d'aller encore mais
pour le roi est faible là
ouais mais le roi blanc aussi et peut
avoir vite du cavalier B6 qui a laissé
trois dame B6
il peut y avoir du cavalier C3 échec
aussi un moment un sacré fils de pièces
là
c'est pas
assez clair moi j'aime pas trop les
blancs
j'ai même un G5 ici
ouais je sais pas moi ça me fait peur
pour le roi blanc mais bon
j'ai jamais rien compris à ces positions
mais j'ai pas des mauvais résultats
c'est ça qui est terrible
du coup je j'en déduis que personne ne
comprend rien
il était il aimait pas cette idée de
tourber 8 et qui a gagné ses trois je
pense pour ça il provoque le cavalier
des cinq à bouger mais le fond en quatre
est pas très bien placé
4 en plus après B6 par exemple B3 il
peut peut-être jouer cavalier BC4 quand
même
beaucoup de cases
tout de suite ok pas mal aussi
qui va bouffer F4 il gagne un temps
pour égalité du coup
c'est possible de mon avis de faire un
peu plus
chaud ce qui fait Maxime là
je sais pas c'est chaud en fait juste
voilà c'est chaud
mais il a de la vente de l'avantage au
temps
ouais mais là ça sert pas à grand-chose
il est moins bien en fait juste mais il
doit faire tourner
une case pour se fout et il menace qui
va gagner 5 attention on a un coup
difficile pour moi
peut-être tenter à 5 quand même
ça faisait partie des coups de l'ordi
mais
là l'ordi te donne un coup
extraordinaire pour les blancs c'est
cavalier aussi
ça marche cavalier
qui emprunt on reprend tu fais quoi
si on prend tout reprend
tu fais roi G7
tu fais exactement ce qu'a fait Maxime
c'est ça qui est fou ok oui et là ça
fait plus que
plus que 23 secondes pour pour Wesley
c'est Maxime qui va jouer le gars qui
non joli très très jolie de la part de
Maxime ce G6
c'est pas la même paire de manches pour
Wesley en face
c'est juste une partie incroyable si je
joue comme ça contre Manu il peut il
peut battre Magnus en jouant comme ça
cette partie elle est fantastique de
juger vraiment du niveau de Maxime dans
ce match dans le sens où il y a eu un un
faux rythme
de de part de par le machin de neige de
par les problèmes techniques de Wesley
etc mais quand western un peu revenu
dans le match à chaque fois Maxime il
sort des parties
fousser 3 un petit pieds jaunes encore
ouais mais attention il y avait roi
je pense
bon ça fait deux points d'écart et on
retourne dans cette partie là Maxime par
contre avait été un peu bizarre
c'est là où il avait donné son deuxième
fou en C7 ouais de manière un peu
étonnante qu'il pouvait commencer je
pense parfois
la dernière partie de cette cadence Baki
et après on passera en belette là où tu
brilles de mille-feu
on va avoir toutes tes expertises tout
est petit tricks pour cliquer plus vite
pour jouer plus vite
les échecs les prémouves
les multiples peut-être que tu nous
lâcheras en quelques-uns de tes
meilleurs secrets
en tout cas je joue mieux en belette que
de notre premier match arrêtez quasiment
maintenant
un joueur redoutable et redouté
on n'a pas envie de croiser Baky 83 en
belette certains ont même arrêté de
jouer en belette après avoir croisé ta
route
tu vas pouvoir nous expliquer un petit
peu tout ça
tu m'avais mis 6-0 la première fois
c'est de là que c'est parti en fait
ça t'avait fait très mal quand même le 6
0 tu t'y attendais pas
tu t'es dit il a un peu nul il a un peu
con je vais quand même le battre mais
ouais c'est ouais
ça avait rendu Maxime très heureux
d'ailleurs ce match
mais le H1 qui a stoppé net le Bullet en
voyant certains Baky 83 monté dans le
classement de chasse comme
sachant que c'est la dernière avec les
prochaines là la partie elle a plus plus
le même goût
[Musique]
et j'espère qu'il y a une pause après
cette partie quand même il y a une pause
bien sûr
ok ouais pas facile de jouer avec
en donnant son fou
et contrôle bien F4
à Maxime qui va peut-être faire qui
menace peut-être G4 dans le G3 F4 par
exemple
joli coup d'un F3
stratégiquement il te fait fou français
et cavalier F4 en fait et après cavalue
aussi ce cavalier des quatre
en fait joue sur le fait qu'il y aura
une structure un peu symétrique mais que
tu es tu as accès avant au casse
mais cavaliers
aussi s'il aime pas du tout
il préfère ah oui parce que 5 qui arrive
aussi
mais là ça va bon après ça va il y a pas
de
il y a pas mort d'homme mais
attention parce que là ça va tuer
peut-être même un cahier des quatre fous
prend pion peut prendre des quatre pour
après jouer pour Besson
non
ça va là
8 ça va aller
juste les pièces qui sont avocat G3 qui
est un peu bizarre
[Musique]
attention à se répète de laisser je suis
revenu là
plus simple on sait jamais ce qui peut
se passer le garder deux trois points
d'écart un point d'écart et tout est
enfin tu es vraiment à portée de fusil
quoi tu fais une connerie et moi je
pense qu'en belette même 0 point d'écart
mais tu lui mets aussi faible que ça
wesh c'est en belette
la bibliothèque
son élo en belote désolé les amis
parce que ça va quand même être
important
après c'est mieux de pas perdre celle là
on est d'accord actuellement il est 2933
en fait
mais classement le plus élevé 3200
et Maxime
je pense que Maxime il joue plus en
belote que
nettement plus de parties
3100 et le mal ils ont même hello max
mais ouais actuellement maxime a plus de
Game il y a un meilleur classement
on aurait recycle il veut recycler son
fou en E7 il va faire roi G7 x 7
peut-être pour jouer G5 un jour il met
un peu de pression quand même là
je trouve que sur le 3 plus 5 il a
dominé dans le jeu Wesley
il a été très copieusement dominé dans
le 5 puissant et dans le 3 plus 5 il est
un peu au dessus
mais la mieux jouer il a nettement mieux
joué avec en 3 + 5 et en 5 puissance ce
qui est bizarre
ah mais je crois vraiment qu'en 5 + 1 il
était il a il avait trop de réellement
moi je regardais un petit peu les
ce qui se passait des fois à l'écran ça
avait l'air d'être capable pour lui
en fait là
il fait confiance à ses capacités
touristiques
on verra Baki
ok deux points d'écart ça me paraît ça
me paraît tranquille
il faudra quand même être méfiant
normalement on va avoir une petite
dizaine de minutes de pause et après il
y a une demi-heure de jeu en belette
c'est ça il y a pas de pause
malheureusement après un quart d'heure
c'est exactement ce que m'avait dit Fab
dans le match de Hikaru contre les
vannes
après 15 minutes et après 30 minutes
là ce qui est un petit peu dommage c'est
qu'on sent que Maxime est trop au dessus
après
sur un match comme celui dit hier
on sent que ça a manqué quand même un
peu un peu de temps de jeu
pour laisser à Fabiano le temps
peut-être de gagner une partie le match
contre
19h j'ai du mal à me rendre compte
est-ce que Fabiano a vraiment mal joué
ou
comme moi aujourd'hui et comme toi mardi
dans ce cas là
au début ça allait à partir d'un moment
il raté tout en fait
et ça lui casser les couilles en fait et
il devait continuer à jouer ça se voyait
ça lui casser les couilles
[Musique]
ouais mais ouais comme Maxime contre
McDo c'est du coup ça va être ça va être
très chaud
ce qui fait ces petits coups de marlou
là il était beau le
J6 qui évalue aussi c'est le genre de
truc qui peuvent lui faire gagner
quelques parties je pense pas qu'il faut
que tu aies peur du score de
Carlson contre Carola mais après
évidemment Magnus quand il joue bien il
est fort
quand même
assez facilement là aujourd'hui bon ça
semble assez on va voir sur le bolet
mais ça va se voir sur le premier volet
de toute façon
mais c'est aussi assez facile
donc ça fait du top 5 clairement dans ce
format
on voit qu'il
pour cette année
on voit qu'il a fait des Blitz des trucs
il est bien préparé non non il est chaud
il est chaud
vendredi non demain c'est NiAl c'est à
15h d'ailleurs
demain c'est Sarine contre Ikaru à 15h
et vendredi 19h
mais oui mais ils ont décalé parce que
sinon en fait ça devait jouer à 15h ça
devait être demain 19h
Maxime Magnus et vendredi 19h la finale
mais en fait c'était impossible
comment tu vas enchaîner trois matchs
comme ça
le matin le matin enfin tu peux pas
et la finale tu dis c'est je crois c'est
mardi
de temps en temps
ouais
enfin pour le coup ça c'est des petites
pauses qui sont qui sont positives
je suis un peu étonné c'est qu'ils aient
pas gardé l'idée de demi-finale finale
sur deux jours où ça je trouve ça cool
et du coup qui n'est pas
en fait je pense que c'est le fait
qu'ils aient mis le quart de finale
aujourd'hui qui les amis dans la sauce
[Musique]
de faire les deux demi-finales le même
jour et la finale le lendemain ça a
assez cool
je trouve que faire les demi-finales et
puis remettre encore quatre jours de
pause et remettre la finale un mardi en
milieu de semaine c'est un peu
allez c'est pendant le title
mais cependant le deuxième title
non même pas ça finit à 23 heures
donc tu peux jouer le title le premier
title commenter la finale et jouer le
deuxième title oui c'est magnifique en
fait
ah oui fantastique
la journée ça peut être
mais bien sûr le plus important c'est le
title
devant chez lui
mais aujourd'hui c'était obligé de
de vérifier qui a gagné
parce que c'est pas parce que ça
klaxonne que c'était la France
pas obligé en tout cas
va toujours et bien sûr ah bah oui
évidemment
je pense pas que
il en est capable tu connais loustique
mais si je contrecarsan il le fera
passer sur
ou alors il le fera parce que il est
trop en sueur
ne vous inquiétez pas
on a toujours su
[Musique]
dans deux points normalement c'est large
mais
attention quand même les deux premières
parties seront décisives en fait si
Maxime fait 2-0
c'est tout de suite c'est tout de suite
gagner à dos
[Musique]
je pense que
ça termine l'important
ah mais il a un mauvais classement
Wesley
classement
il faut que ça reprenne là
allez Dany
peut-être parce qu'il est nul quoi
c'est vrai que c'est une bonne raison
je sais pas pourquoi parce qu'il est nul
ré tout à l'heure je pense que c'est un
peu des deux
c'est un peu des deux
bon le plus important qu'est-ce que tu
as ravitailler Kevin je fais carpaccio
et soupe
[Musique]
au bout d'un moment c'est tout ça va
mieux là aujourd'hui c'est le premier
jour ça va un peu mieux mais c'est très
très loin d'aller bien
mais bon là il faut que je récupère ma
faut vraiment que je prenne du temps que
je récupère l'énergie terrestre et j'en
ai plus
c'était la fin de mon année quoi
et alors
du monde rapides je te cache pas surtout
champion du monde de rapidité je te
cache pas
ça
je prends un titre de champion du monde
de rapides ou de Blitz vs sans speech en
fait je te le dis tout de suite
[Musique]
mais quand même un titre de champion du
monde de Sébastien j'espère que tu
parles
Sébastien Mazet
le plus beau quand même
quand même aussi faudrait qu'il gagne
peut-être quelque chose ça va peut-être
le complètement le débloquer
comme une belle saison l'avenir qui va
démarrer on sait toujours pas quand ce
qu'il y a toujours pas de date pour le
match Championnat du Monde digne des
pomyachi
là c'est sûr que ce sera pas marre
c'était censé être mars mais là il y a
plus de date il y a plus rien
c'est quand même important oui il y a
pas de
après je sais pas pourquoi on t'explique
tout le temps que c'est le ouais les
échecs c'est très important de sauver le
cycle mais te disais un certain email
sous-ovski ouais faut quand même faut
qu'il carbure là pour le sauver parce
que on a un peu dans le mal
c'est bizarre qu'ils n'ont pas ok ça
reprend c'est ça ça doit être difficile
quand c'est la chose principale de ton
travail bah qui et que c'est le un peu
le seul truc important que tu as à faire
tous les deux ans c'est quand même pas
facile à réaliser
pourquoi j'ai pas la partie moi je l'ai
la partie c'est du Bullet là bas qui
j'ai l'impression qu'il fait déjà un peu
de la merde
il a mal choisi
celle-là elle est pas facile à jouer en
belette ça c'est un punto à Wesley
il y a pas trop de match en belette
faut aussi
[Musique]
mettre les tours en D8 en 8 en C8 après
sur les colonnes
j'imagine pour Wesley
attention il y a le 4 qui peut qui peut
faire peur ici la Tour Eiffel
tour des 8
cavaliers à 4 il veut échanger les
chevaux
ces choses faites maintenant
cavaliers C5 il touche le fou ici c'est
peut-être du 4 ouais qui part
c'est dur pour Wesley
intermédiaire qui fait très mal qui
prend la pièce
et sinon faut trouver un coup avec les
décape prise et même fous des cinq ou
fuj4 ici j'ai 4 à l'air fort des 5 aussi
c'est le plus positionnel j'aurais fait
attention à trop intermédiaire peut-être
malin dame B5 fois peut-être attention
c'est pas grave ça me huit il se laisse
pas dans le vis-à-vis cavalier à 6
peut-être du cavalier G4 F5 maintenant
qui peut partir de l'autre côté
cavalier BK
il va faire quoi
ça joue pas mal quand même un côté
Wesley attention
un peu plus rapide un peu plus fort
il a joué quelques coups facile quand
même parce que il est bien revenu Wesley
dans la partie mais le Maxime il avait
de la marge
Maxime avait de la marge c'est vrai
il a joué un peu facile deux trois coups
mais bon il sera pour les prochains
et les chevaux ça fait des fourchettes
on la voit arriver la fourchette
on la sent
attention qui décale pas son roi c'est
bien joué de la part de Maxime
et c'est genre de final ou quand tu as
du temps c'est peut-être mieux au blanc
mais quand t'as pas de temps
tu peux rien faire allez leur dire non
c'est plus de 20 mais c'était un jouable
raison il a fait des bons coups quand
même faut pas il faut pas minimiser le
Wesley il a pas forcément encore la tête
dedans
foncer parce qu'il a ça a pas l'air
d'être un mauvais joueur de Bullet et tu
vois heureusement qu'il a quand même les
deux points d'écart un Maxime à égalité
sur un peu moins serein
là on est quand même assez William
non ça échange au centre
c'était c'était dans le
dans l'événement Société Générale
qui était parti qui avait fait l'écart
Maxime qui s'inspire des meilleurs du
coup et oui
quand même un finaliste qui avait joué
ce dame B3
certains ritales 44 non
qui avait fait une qui avait une
victoire express avec ce dame B3 et là
position
de nouveau peut-être un peu plus
agréable avec les Noirs finalement
il faut les avoir dans votre manche
il monte il monte sa position il joue un
peu plus vite
il commence à faire peur
il commence à faire suer
allez c'est bien joué la maxime qui a
bien placé son cavalier vers des 4
il va pouvoir bientôt l'installer
une bonne nouvelle je pense ça échange
beaucoup de pièces côté Wesley
B4 c'était pas la meilleure inspiration
de Wesley pour jouer le gars en tout cas
mais attention quand même il y a un
meilleur structure pour pour les Noirs
évidemment avec beaucoup de temps c'est
très simple de faire nul en belette
comme ça faut toujours se méfier il y a
peut-être du E5 là qui part
mais la tour en C2 ça y est Maxime qui
va échanger
ça devrait pas être très compliqué mais
quand même il faut pas faut pas relâcher
il peut faire partir le roi de l'autre
côté
et là ça peut être la double tranchant
et 8
il prend des risques mais Wesley il va
faire nul il n'y a pas le 4 ici non
c'est 8
attention quand même Maxime
parce que c'est le Pione qui file
c'est le Pione qui file backy
heureusement qu'il y en a qu'un il y en
a pas d'Oche alors est-ce qu'il va faire
tourcer 6 ou 3D d'eux attention quand
même il va vite hein ce pion
il va très très vite
jusqu'en 2 en dame
attention quand même
il va vite ce pion il va très vite ce
pion et c'est tourner trois tours 3 il
va beaucoup trop vite allez Maxime qui
peut peut-être encore la sauver
mais il y a peut-être un dame en réalité
et tous les pions sont coupés le pion B
peut plus avancer
et le roi qui va venir se charger du
pion G
sans trop de difficultés
et Maxime qui abandonne attention Baki
il faudrait pas avoir un frisson ici
plus qu'un point d'écart et on n'a pas
on n'a pas l'impression que Maxime est
tant que ça au dessus de son adversaire
dans cette cadence il va falloir qu'il
trouve des positions un peu plus
compliquées
oh que oui
la plus lumière ouais mais c'est
franchement quand tu vois comment le
match est serré tu dis que les multiples
problèmes de Wesley nous ont quand même
enlevé une belle épine du pied parce que
il a été dans des conditions pour jouer
qui était
encore des problèmes
tu te dis quand même que il y a qu'un
point d'écart
et que le match il était plus que
compliqué pour lui à jouer
c'est quoi cette bibliothèque du Sheitan
ouais c'est un peu la question qu'on se
pose mais pourquoi il rallume la lumière
c'est bizarre qui s'éteignent qui se
rallument là je crois qu'elle sait pas
complètement rallumée ça m'a l'air
d'être un peu kata mais bon il joue
Wesley
qui s'appelle une pièce il faut jouer
aussi
exact mais là ça fait
c'est limite non
pour Maxime mais c'est juste encore
faut aussi vite Maxime fausse dépêcher
là faut pas que ça lui échappe
il a que 20 secondes
4 aussi attention ça peut être une
possibilité
allez c'est bien ceux qui tank un tout
petit peu trop de temps
ah mais il trouve cette solution et
attention le 4 peut-être qui va arriver
allez cette fois-ci prend
c'est peut-être bien ça pour Maxime
à jouer
là ça peut être bien tourné pour Maxime
pas une pièce de trop
il va sûrement
on en parle souvent des fous cette fois
c'est mieux que d'un mec cavalier encore
une fois la date
allez là c'est bien la dame qui passe
par derrière
le prison 4 c'est fini là il refait son
ouh là là
il passe par derrière maintenant Maxime
avec la dame
ça va peut-être faire l'échec perpétuel
audame Pro 5 pas vu de
la maxime qui est plus du tout en
contrôle bah qui
il a sorti la boîte à gaffe
que Wesley a mal géré aussi il devrait
s'en sortir dans cette dans cette
il s'en est pas ouais c'est pas fait bah
qui encore c'est pas tirer il y a quand
même deux punto de moi
il peut encore la tenir peut-être mais
elle est dure
dans ma tête ça repasse par derrière
c'est pas trois fois merde je croyais
que c'était trois fois
l'ordinateur d'un égal quand même
quasiment maintenant ouais c'est qui a
raté une grosse chance parce que les
pions sont sur blanc
c'est pas la bonne couleur
c'est hyper tendu
il y a le Punto qui parle
Maxime qui en envoie des deux côtés
dans ma chambre
absolument infernale elle vaut très très
cher celle-là
ça peut faire tilt l'un ou l'autre ok
oui
après le titre est plus cher pour ça vu
que il y aurait
de nouveaux deux points d'écart
la partie qui est bouillante
c'est le niveau de jeu et et hallucinant
comment est-ce qu'ils n'ont toujours
rien gaffé les deux
ouais ce sont des monstres
le pion qui continue d'avancer à
ça tient encore sur un fil
je crois que ça tient il a eu la il a eu
du bol là Maxime
et ça va tenir le pouvoir réussir à
revenir
au
tiens ça apparemment oui c'est quoi
cette position c'est incroyable
ah ouais c'est trop
là le bol est incroyable
un salaire complètement perdant et ça
tient c'est fou il va quand même mettre
le cavalier en D8
incroyable et mais je pense que c'est au
tempo sur les couleurs et tout je pense
que c'est ce que tu peux pas
triangulaire avec un cavalier
c'est pas banal cette position
OK
on a eu beaucoup de chance sur celle-là
pour la dernière ASV tôt ouais après ça
c'est quand même bien tourné quoi
de temps en temps
ça s'est joué à rien mais il a failli
mater même maximum incroyable qu'on soit
ramené son roi vers H2 H3 tiens moi je
veux le serais pris le dans ma chambre
j'aurais oublié c'était très loin
c'était très loin de Maxime c'est très
marloud
et du coup je me serais occupé du pion
ah et j'aurais complètement oublié
l'autre menace
parce que ça lui a fait perdre trois
quatre secondes
et c'est peut-être qu'il lui a manqué
allez on a tout on a tout pour nous
baquis
mais le damas était incroyable il y en a
tellement qui se le serait pris
je pense quasiment tout le monde en fait
il y en a peut-être 10-15 au monde qui
se le prennent pas il a joué tempo
il a toujours su
mais là il continue à dominer un Wesley
un thème de Maxime et tempo le
par contre ça
c'était pas un punto
qui est faible derrière bizarre qu'il a
commencé par qui est pris en B2 il a
sûrement oublié
il y a à deux qui tombent mais il y a
des six qui tombent ça va peut-être être
égal au final
quoi que
c'est peut-être mieux au blanc ça non
j'aime pas trop là
il a voulu éviter ouais j'ai compris
un truc avec Dame des trois tours D8 qui
peut tomber de l'autre côté mais la
roche 3
dans ma chambre
j'ai quatre forcés sur X jeux à Tours
géant
ça tombe quand même trop ça tombe très
bien pour nous encore que ce soit pas
complètement foutu ouais Maxime qui a la
baraka là sur ces parties
il va pas falloir
ça
tient encore
ouais c'est la baraka que ce soit pas
mal hein ça aurait pu encore mais qui
gagne là
on part avec le roi
monte encore
il s'en sort peut-être toi
c'est joli
peut-être B3
allez maintenant c'est toi
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué
Baky c'est terrible il a raté d'un pro 4
il faut le faire incroyable
quel niveau de jeu des deux côtés
incroyable et c'est égalité Baky
attention
s'assume mais qu'est-ce que ça envoie
c'est qui va dans une petite finale
dans chaque cadence il augmente son
niveau ah ouais là c'est
Maxime qui défend lui aussi extrêmement
bien on peut pas dire que Maxime soit en
dessous du niveau qu'on attend là dans
ses premières parties la dernière partie
elle est fantastique simplement et le
niveau de jeu de Wesley et il est
Stratos
[Musique]
c'est énorme en face en fait là ce qui
est en train de se passer et c'est pas
pour rien qu'il arrivait deux fois la
fille en finale contre
Caro
c'est pas pour rien Wesley on savait que
c'est un gros morceau
surtout il est capable de jouer très
très vite
allez faut que Maxime réussisse à nous
faire quelque chose de bien ici elle
leur dit d'un fous prend le 4 allez
let's go ça part let's go
ça part de là
enfin une gaffe
ça fait plaisir
et ouais et en plus il paye cher parce
qu'il avait une tellement bonne position
là c'est un cocon de double
allez il faut réussir à la terminer mais
elle a l'air assez facile
mais ça doit aller pour Maxime il doit y
avoir encore du Tour G4 tout simplement
décalés la tour
elle est pas encore gagnée évidemment
ah mais ça ça fait du bien
elle a pas l'air très dur quand même
Baki
il a l'air elle a l'air assez facile et
cavalier 4 échec
allez ça c'est gagné alors prends un
point d'avance
allez Maxime là qui a eu le qui a trouvé
le coup au meilleur des moments
il était important là il en reste
combien de parties il en reste 4
peut-être 3 3 peut-être plus tôt et
c'est un point d'avance
solide
ça c'est bien choisi il va répéter
peut-être
après ça rajoute pas de partie vu que ça
prend pas de temps
c'est pas ça qui va enlever des parties
backi malheureusement
il faut jouer
mais la position est correcte pour
Maxime
Cup
c'est des positions qui maîtrisent quand
même relativement bien Maxime puisque
c'est lui-même un joueur de nage d'orf
en dessin qui va faire mal au F5
attention de ouais faut prendre
ça pas été joué il arrive plus à faire à
mettre la tête sous l'eau ah ouais à la
pendule attention à vous prend et des 5
aussi
qui peuvent être des idées pour le
moment
il joue de l'autre côté
ça échange les tours il y a peut-être un
punto en B5 non qui traîne l'enfant de
variante
complexe il y a peut-être prises et
cavaliers 3 4
et tes 5 il y a peut-être un cavalier C7
ouais
par Maxime allez c'est bien la maxime et
peut-être en train de le gagner ce match
dans ces deux parties
qui tient encore
c'est jouer qui prend aussi puis on
prend aussi
4 qui tombe derrière il y a cavalier G3
encore un qui défend la maison
il fait tes 4 et mais maintenant c'est
vrai qu'il y a le pion C2 qui est un peu
arriérée
des deux cavaliers à 4 cavaliers à 6
c'est 3 qui revient en C5 ça c'est
plutôt une bonne opérations
et ça fait quoi ça fait deux pions de
plus pour Maxime
pas complètement fini encore mais
il y a fubéca qui va arriver de l'autre
côté il s'embrouille
il y a pas de maths en C1
allez ça y est c'est en train de
de se préciser Maxime qui a déjà une
balle de match mais tu vois il fallait
pas laisser
ah ouais c'est un bon
égalité là au début des violettes
elle est pas facile à jouer avec les
Noirs c'est le fupron E4 qui aura qui a
décidé du sort du match si il ne
rechange pas de demain
cette position est pas facile anglais et
la neige
attention
ça va laisser 6 qui rentre il va y avoir
la tour qui va revenir en C1
mais peut-être
un peu le il a perdu un peu le fil du
match
j'ai l'impression de depuis le
coup de Trafalgar de Maxime
il avait tout hein quand il lui a fait
il faut prendre à 5 ma très Marlo
maximum il avait il avait la ligne parce
que là puis on prend en cavalier c'est
ça qui peut aller gratter une qualité
peut-être en B3 3 6 mais ça fait
peut-être juste perpète et perpète c'est
quasiment gain ah il reste 6 minutes
donc il restera encore deux parties
vont apprendre à me laisser échec je
pense qu'il va juste faire nulle Maxime
avec le temps
il reste il restera juste deux parties
comme ça joue autant il reste juste de
partir
ça ouais c'est le c'est pas forcément
ouais mais là c'est bien non pour Maxime
[Musique]
ça fait quand même la diff
et là Wesley maintenant qui est un peu
dans l'obligation de gagner
mais qui ne va pas y arriver
en B2 ça va être trouvé par Maxime c'est
terrible pour Wesley et Kylie B2 à
chaque fois qu'il a été obligé il a bien
joué Maxime et oui
CAC 40 3 points d'écart
cette fois ci c'est sûr que c'est gagné
ce sera joué finalement en dernier
recours sur sur le fou prend 4
et on verra on verra en demi du coup
contre Magnus il faudra quand même jouer
un peu plus fort encore Batman
à chaque fois où il était
où il a dû gagner bon il a des chances
quand même il a fait quand même OK
[Musique]
qui a complètement craqué après quand
ils savent que les matchs sont terminés
comme comme là c'est
c'est plus pareil mais ça fait ça fait
trois points d'écart
ouais ce sera la dernière ou lavant
dernière partie comme il a abandonné
vite il s'en est peut-être racheter une
dernière
et Wesley qui montre à Ludwig comment ne
pas jouer la française
c'est important
ouais
c'est quand la demie c'est demain ouais
du coup là il abandonne vite pour
essayer de se faire une des parties mais
il y en a plus il y en a plus assez
Noël vous prend quatre il a fait
complètement tilt hein dans la confiance
peut-être parce que avant ça c'était fou
incroyables aussi bien
c'est logique ouais ça finissait
toujours ça finissait toujours par
craquer
ici il a gagné Maxime quand même contre
0 chance
non ça dépend après
il faut que Maxime soit vraiment au top
se met en confiance et que il fait un
mauvais début de match ce sera mort par
contre si Magnus commence à faire deux
trois fautes tactique et que Maxime le
fait douter my Magnus il est moins
précis après
là il a mieux joué encore que contre que
comprenait pas au Maxime
il laisse pas du tout reprendre des deux
dames ces trois à une pièce en décapant
bon peu importe là c'est terminé donc on
se retrouvera demain 15h quand même pour
le match NiAl Sarine contre Hikaru
on verra ça farine pour moi très
étonnant de le voir là mais
tu en profiter pour répondre à Dark
Jiraya quand même sur le chat je fais
des dédicaces
et là c'est fini direct
comment ça c'est fini direct après cette
partie là le match est fini il y a pas
de pause non c'est fini
là il y a plus de pause là ouais c'est
un peu étonnant je suis d'accord avec
toi ça finit trop vite en fait
ça finit trop vite
à demain
ou plus ou moins en fait c'est pour ça
que je dis que Karo Anna faut pas
vraiment tenir compte du score de Magnus
faites vite le match il est fini après
c'est enfin c'était un peu ça et le
matière
mais c'est pas fini en fait oui on n'a
pas entendu le
c'est fini ce que c'est fini mais c'est
pour ça qu'il faut pas tenir compte des
scores un peu fleuves parce que
tu es mené ok tu es mené 10-4 tu sais
que tu as perdu bon c'est un peu on voit
un peu ça
comme tous les matchs donc
mais après ça joue quand même sur les
prix ouais je sais
pourquoi pas prendre des Punto
faire une rapide là il savent tous les
deux que c'est fini mais du coup elle
est le joueur qui a perdu généralement
il y a après il lâche donc faut pas
tenir compte des scores encore la
lumière qui s'éteint qui se rallume
on va faire comme la dernière fois on va
faire un raid
sur la sur la
chaîne de chaise comme pour que vous
ayez
les interviews d'après match
comme ça on le prépare pour pas que vous
le ratiez et on se retrouvera demain 15h
au revoir
je pense que je pense que être un peu je
pense qu'il s'en fout aussi
qui va pouvoir les lire des livres là
je pense même pas vraiment en fait
il y en a absolument rien à [ __ ] je
pense ouais c'est possible aussi ouais
et c'est pas comment il va rentrer à la
maison surtout ouais ouais avec la neige
le machin
la vraie je pense que lui il doit dire
ouais bon dans ces conditions de façon
c'était dur de faire mieux machin et
sans tabac le Boulard
ouais ouais c'est pas c'est pas évident
quoi
le match de Magnus sera sympa donc
normalement vendredi mais
on vous tiendra au courant quand même
parce que on sait jamais tous les ça il
y a eu tellement de changements
et un peu alors
Wesley qui peut finir sur une bonne note
c'est pas forcément que le chrono est
mort donc il a raison de continuer à
jouer mais ouais là il a peut-être
terminé quatre points d'écart ouais
match quand même relativement serré Baki
heureusement que que Maxime a pris large
au début
parce qu'après ça pas ça pas été ça pas
été de tout repos sur ce ben j'envoie le
raid et on vous dit bah demain pour la
suite merci à tous ciao ciao à demain